welcome to a alt shift X live stream to
discuss House of the Dragon episode 7.
and uh my God things are rapidly
spiraling out of control uh the the
battle lines are truly being drawn
between the greens and Rainier's side uh
we had this this wonderful confrontation
between Alice and Andrea after their
respective children
assaulted each other and an eye was cut
out of amond targaryen's face uh we
after aemond had claimed Vega the
largest most powerful weapon of war in
this universe is now in the hands of
this of this child of this angry little
blonde kid uh he is now in control of uh
the world's biggest nuke Vega the drag
again
so we've got a whole different sort of
dragon situation now Vega used to be
Lena valarion's dragon and it is now
being claimed by aemond
to the outrage of Lena's children Baylor
and Rayna Targaryen Rayna had hoped to
claim Vega for herself she wanted to
claim her mother's Dragon but that that
Birthright was taken from her by amond
Targaryen
so anyway welcome to the live stream
this was a huge episode we're going to
talk all about it we're going to answer
your questions
we are not going to spoil anything for
future episodes except for at the very
end of the live stream we will have a
quick glance at the on the next episode
preview but um otherwise we're going to
avoid spoilers we're going to answer
your questions thanks for joining in
um and thank you for the live streams
Jess says laris's relationship with
Alison is like if Littlefinger was more
open to Catelyn about how just creep how
creepy and conniving he was yeah so we
got some interesting scenes with Laris
and Allison
um Polaris was staring at Alison
throughout the funeral and Kristen even
said like hey Allison like you your your
dude is staring at you this guy is being
weird and Ellison's like yeah I know he
does that like that that was kind of the
vibe and then Laris came up later
towards the end of the episode and told
Allison that like hey like if you ever
need anyone murdered I'm your guy
um like Lara said oh you know I I heard
that uh you wanted uh lucerus's eye uh
you know I could I can do that for you
I've got an eye guy I know a guy for
that if you want me to mutilate some
children I'll do it so Alison has that
card to play up her sleeve and yeah I
agree just with your comparison to
Littlefinger um because Littlefinger in
in the Game of Thrones show and in the
books has this whole like weird creepy
obsession with Catelyn Stark and with
catelyn's daughter uh Sansa
um and like
Laris Littlefinger is someone who uses
spies and who uses murder and who uses
manipulation
um and a big part of littlefinger's
motivation is that he was rejected by
Catlin as a child
um I mean he tried to fight Brandon
Stark for the hand of um Catelyn Stark
and that did not end well for him he got
cut opened from from his belly button to
his collarbone and he always had a chip
on his shoulder about that and he wanted
to sort of punish the world for you know
belittling him and and rejecting him and
so you know and Littlefinger is like a
small dude who's not very physically
strong which is similar to Laris being
sort of physically weak with his
clubfoot and stuff
um so
I think in a big way like Littlefinger
is trying to get back at everyone and
trying to prove himself worthy and
trying to win the affections of the
woman that he is like creepily obsessed
with so with Littlefinger that's Sansa
um and it seems that with Laris it's
more about uh Alison with him so yeah
there there is definitely some parallels
there I think there's still a lot more
mystery with what Larissa's game is
though like to what extent is larus like
genuinely motivated by an obsession with
Alison and to what extent is Laris just
trying to get power for himself
so I you know I think and you know
there's still the whole sort of mystery
of like how does Laris know what he
knows like is there some possibility of
some magical angles with him I think
larys is still very mysterious but yeah
I do think Littlefinger is a good
comparison
um thanks for the Super Chat from Leah
who says call back to when Arya and Joff
were fighting and King Robert had to
figure that out yes so we had this scene
like after the children fought we had
this scene where viserys uh
ineffectually attempted to make some
justice
um and that is similar to in Game of
Thrones season one episode two when
there was that fight between Arya and
Joffrey
um when Joffrey was being a [ __ ] and
he like attacked arya's friend Micah and
so I uh pulled pulled Joffrey's sword
and used a direwolf and like beat the
prince into submission
and so and then afterwards we had this
scene
um where Robert was like well hell Seven
Hills what am I to do about this you
know my family is fighting amongst
themselves
um and Cersei I believe like demanded
our
Aya's hand to be cut off because she
attacked uh Joffrey maybe that's only in
the books
um but you know in a very similar way
you know Alison in this episode demanded
the mutilation of uh Rainier's son
luceris valerion because of the fight
um and you know in the same way that
Robert in Game of Thrones just failed to
make any kind of real Justice or any
real kind of amends viserys completely
failed like like viserys at one point
was like well okay like I guess you guys
I I guess there's been a a fight and I'm
just gonna leave I'm just gonna declare
this done even though no one was
Satisfied by the outcome no one felt
like justice was done and that's why
Alison picked up the dagger and tried to
make her own Justice
um so this shows us how like viserys's
complete lack of authority he's like
complete lack of strength means that
everyone else like fills that power
vacuum and tries to make their own
Justice in their own bloody horrible way
so uh yeah definitely a very similar
scene uh thanks for the super super chat
from carnifex who says that Leno gets a
happy ending yeah I I I'm pretty happy
about uh Lenor and Carl making the
excellent decision to leave before the
[ __ ] hits the fan although one of the
the details you know like um what
happened was that Lenor and Carl faked
the death of lanor um but but they did
they did uh kill someone because like
what they did was they threw a corpse
into the fireplace
um at driftmark to make it look like
that was lenor's body so that everyone
thinks lane or is dead so that he's free
to run off to the East and just hang out
with his boy
um
but I wonder whose corpse is in the
fireplace
someone died like they they I mean I
don't know maybe they got the corpse
from a morgue or something does
driftmark have a morgue maybe they got
one of the corpses From the Bottom of
the Sea where the valerions throw all of
their dead corpses here's a theory for
you here's here's a really horrifying
Theory what if the corpse that Leno and
Carl used to fake Leno's death what if
this corpse is Lena valarion's corpse
what if he used his own dead sister's
corpse to fake his own death
if you want to get really morbid and
horrible because it's just there it's
there it's fresh yeah no I no they
didn't do that they would have used like
a male body and I think the feet were
mostly unburned so I don't know maybe it
would have had to have been a valerion
like it would have had to have been the
corpse of someone who looks like Lenor
am I crazy uh Bubba was taken in the
live chat says it was the guy Daemon
killed
the guard Daemon knocked down okay yes
okay you guys are right you guys are
correct it must have been the person who
Davon killed yeah all right I was
enjoying my fan Theory but I'm yes I'm
sure you guys are right they used the
guard that Daemon killed on the stairs
which you know I feel like is kind of
yeah this guy that must be the guy who
they used in the fireplace I feel like
it's more morally interesting if
um
I feel like it's more morally
interesting if Leno and Carl actually
did murder someone in order to escape to
their life of Freedom uh thanks for the
Super Chat from Shane who says
exhausting hiding behind the cloak of
your own righteousness yeah so that was
Rainier's dialogue to Alison in that
confrontation
um where
you're was sort of enjoying Alison
attacking her because rhaenyra was
saying that like this reveals how Alison
has it out for her like elephant is
always acting like she's just doing the
right thing she's the one who's
following the rules
um but now Alison reveals to the world
that rhaenyra has a grudge against
rhaenyra and is willing to mute at least
children to do it and they talked in the
inside the episode about how Allison is
always so like emotionally repressed
like Alison is always acting proper
she's never revealing her true feelings
and now her emotion just like bursts out
in like this crazy violent moment
um so no one's even hiding it anymore
like up until now like everyone's sort
of pretending that they're all getting
along but this is sort of the moment
when it's very clear that like there are
sides now you're either on rhaenyra's
side or you're on Alison's side
um and they like they stand in those
sides at this moment the valerians
supporting rhaenyra
um and the Hightower is supporting
Allison and her children so um
my God uh we've got some discussion of
sea smoke in the live chat because yeah
there's a bit of dragon claiming
Shenanigans going on so
amond has claimed Vega because Lane of
larion died and now Lenor valerion has
died as well and he has a dragon called
sea smoke so now that Lenor is dead uh
sea smoke is up for grabs someone
someone will get this
um handsome dragon
um I wonder who could claim it I mean I
I guess the the one person who could
claim it is Raina Targaryen right
um
Rayna Targaryen is the one of Daemon and
Lena's kids who don't have dragons
Baylor has her own young dragon called
morning uh no called uh Moon Dancer who
we haven't seen yet so I guess Rayna
might claim sea smoke that would make
sense we'll see what happens there but
there are several dragons like Verma
Thor and Silverwing are the old dragons
of King joharis The Old King jahiris and
alisane and they're hanging around on on
Dragonstone or on King's Landing there's
a bunch of little hatchlings and stuff
around
um there's potentially like a whole
bunch of dragons that are that are um
that could be claimed I mean in the
books with amond
um King viserys says to aemond like hey
like you know while we're on driftmark
for Lena's funeral
um or Lena's funeral in the books uh
visery says like hey like amond like if
you're brave enough maybe you can claim
a dragon at Dragonstone on our way back
you can grab a dragon egg go to grab a
hatchling
um and amond was like you know [ __ ] that
I don't want a little hatchling I don't
want a little egg I'm gonna take the
biggest weapon of war in the world
um and so you know and I enjoyed amon's
like ego trip after he he rides this
massive creature and I really enjoyed
the dragon riding sequence of you know
being battered by Seagulls And barely
Clinging On It Was a Very sort of fun
fantasy moment but but I enjoyed when
you know aemond came back from his
flight and you know this kid who had
been bullied and who felt looked down
upon suddenly has this Rush of power
like this child experiences control over
the most powerful force in the world so
it feels very believable that he would
have this crazy power rush and would
feel vindictive against you know people
who you know after he had felt bullied
and so he starts bashing people with
rocks I mean it's horrible psychotic
behavior but it sort of makes sense with
what we know of aemond
I thought it was crazy how like these
kids that they're like throwing punches
and stuff in this brawl between
Rainier's sons and and aegon's Sons and
Baylor and Rayna
um like they were really throwing like
punches around and that sort of makes
sense because like you know we we saw
these kids training in the yard you know
like these children have been trained to
fight so you know they're capable of
doing more damage to each other than
they otherwise would
um so you know all of this violence it's
the consequences of the training that
these children have been given like they
dressed them up in opposing colors green
for aegon and amond and black and red
for Jason Luke and so when you pit these
kids against each other it's it's not a
surprising outcome
um when they turn against each other
uh some people in the live chat are
suggesting that rhaenyra was also in on
lanor and Carl escaping yeah okay okay
the consensus is that it was Rainier's
idea to let Lena go alive and that's why
they were talking about like ruling
through Terror and like seeming to be
yeah okay you guys have convinced me it
was Rainier's plan to let Lena go Grant
him this kindness set him free yeah okay
you guys are right Lenor and Rainier and
Damon were playing to let them go free
yeah okay anyway let's move on
um thanks for the Super Chat from Uniden
who says Lara strong channeling the dude
you want an eye I can get you an eye
dude thanks for the Super Chat from John
who says 99 sure that Helena is a
dreamer yeah we got a little bit of more
strange dialogue from Helena Targaryen
in this episode so Helena is the
daughter of King viserys and Alison
Hightower and in the previous episode we
saw Helena saying some weird stuff about
a millipede
um and the number of legs that it has
and then Helena also said amond will
have to close an eye
um and so they were talking about like
amond wanting to claim a dragon and aim
and Helena was suggesting that to get a
dragon emot will have to close an eye
and indeed in this episode aemond loses
an eye that's cut out from him but he
also gets a dragon and then Amon later
says well I lost an eye but I got the
biggest most powerful Dragon in the
world so it's a fair trade
so Helena maybe saw the future
like Helena somehow had a dream a
Targaryen Dragon dream maybe that aemond
would lose an eye but get a dragon so um
yeah I think it's pretty much confirmed
that Helena can see the future she
doesn't you know I mean she might not
fully understand her Visions like
Targaryen Dragon dreams are often
metaphorical it's hard to interpret them
they're like symbolic so you know Helena
might not be able to like warn amond
that hey someone's gonna cut your eye
out but like her words might give us
some insight into what might happen in
the future and so in this episode Helena
says hand turns Loom spool of green
spool of black dragons of Flesh dragons
of thread so I think that you know I I
think that that is a symbolic
description of the royal family
um like I think that she's talking about
the bloodline like when she talks about
a loom like a loom is a machine that
makes cloth and fabric by weaving
together threads just like the royal
family weaves together the Bloodlines of
different people into like a fabric of
like time and history and family threads
of red threads of green like targaryens
and high Towers intermarrying creating
the the fabric of the royal family so I
think this particular line is not
necessarily a prediction of the future
it's just a sort of a symbolic
description of the royal family and it
fits with like the bloodline stuff
um so I think that's lovely dialogue
some people in the live chart are
talking about how um Lenor shaves his
head to hide his Valyrian silver hair to
like hide that he's Leno uh valerion so
that he can escape and there is a
potential similarity there to Varys
because Varys
um some people theorize that Varys might
be a Targaryen or a Valyrian or
something I mean he is from lease and
like lease like people in lease do have
Village variant features a lot of the
time but some people do theorize because
like in the books there's all this stuff
about the black fires and it seems as
though there's a connection between like
illyrio and Varys and this kid young
grief it's a whole thing but uh yeah it
is a cool theory in the books that Varys
might actually be a secret Targaryen or
a secret blackfyre or a secret Valerian
of some flavor and he might shave his
head to hide that particular fact
thanks for the Super Chat from Dopey
Dragon who says the lean or twist not
only makes the blacks look less bad for
no reason but also makes no sense what
will happen to Sea smoke I don't know I
don't know if it doesn't make sense I
think it you know if Rainier and Daemon
decided to you know free Lenor and Carl
and let them get away that that does
make Rainier and Daemon look like Good
Guys compared to Alison looking like a
bad guy because she you know tried to
cut out a child's eye this episode
um so you know I don't think it I think
it's fine it's um it but it does make
Rainier a
um and Daemon look good while it makes
Alison look bad in this episode
thanks for the Super Chat from Benson
who says I'm going to bed Emma
yeah
um so viserys mistakenly called his wife
Alison by the name of his previous wife
Emma which is uh dark it's it's a downer
it looks like viserys is starting to
lose his marbles a bit a bit of dementia
setting in even though he's only meant
to be like like 30 or even less than 30.
he looks really old because of his
disease
um but viserys is not an old man he just
seems to be aging before his time under
the weight of his disease and his
responsibilities
I kind of enjoyed uh daemon's
performance throughout these scenes
where like everyone around Daemon is
like sad and unsettled
um and and turbulent with all of these
grudges and Ambitions and daemon's like
yeah I've been like this the whole time
like you know when Daemon was leaning
against the wall at this scene with um
Allison and rhaenyra attacking each
other like like I think Daemon was
quietly enjoying himself watching all of
the conflict because Daemon has always
felt conflicted and Daemon has always
felt grudges and Daemon has always felt
like he had he doesn't have what he's
deserved
um so I think Daemon Daemon quietly
enjoying that was a nice addition
thanks for the
oh yeah no sorry yeah viserys is not 30.
he's he is like 50. that does make sense
because he would because Daemon was
sorry viserys was not yet 30 when he
married Allison so now it's been like 10
years later so yeah he I think viserys
is like 40 now
maybe it's like 4 40.
I mean we could figure it out like if we
go to
uh check that when viserys was born
I mean do we really need to know exactly
how old is I think he's like 40.
um I mean we don't know what we don't
know exactly what year it is in Hot D
right now and Hot D doesn't necessarily
follow the chronology of these things
um
yeah anyway thanks for the Super Chat
from tambi Lee who says Kristen Cole
didn't train the bastards as much as he
trained Alison's boys yeah so I mean
Harwin strong last episode said
um that
you're not training Jason Luke as well
as your training
um the other kids
um uh he's he the whole thing with
Kristen training the kids and being a
dick about it reminded me of uh Alyssa
Thorne
I remember in Game of Thrones when
Alison Thorne was like the cruel uh
teacher who trained the Night's Watch
people and Alyssa like played favorites
and he was really cruel to Sam tarly uh
when he was training the Night's Watch
kids and I think that
Kristen Cole was similar when he was
like clearly showing favoritism towards
aegon and Amon so yeah like maybe that's
a good point maybe that's part of why
um amond managed to beat Jace and Luke
and the girls it's because he was like
trained better
thanks for the Super Chat from Jess who
says you targaryens and your weird
Customs yeah that's true so Allison's
previously uh was like acting disgusted
at the prospect of Rainier and Daemon
hooking up because it's incestuous but
we learn in this episode that uh aegon
and Helena are now betrothed to marry
each other uh aegon being the firstborn
child of viserys and Allison and Helena
being aegon's Sister
um so Allison was being weird before
about Targaryen incest but now she's
getting her own children to participate
in Targaryen incest
thanks for the Super Chat from Big Daddy
who says I'm surprised crispy Cole
didn't jump at the opportunity to take
the kids eye yeah it's interesting that
Kristen Cole was one of the more uh
peaceful and relaxed people in this
confrontation uh like he did not
immediately obey Alison when Alison told
him hey I want you to cut out Luke's eye
and that stands in contrast to when
Kristen Cole you know beat Joffrey
Joffrey londmuth to death when he talked
about Kristen's secret so Kristen maybe
has learned a little bit of restraint I
mean it's a bit like the restraint that
Christian showed with Harwin
um so like you know when in the previous
episode Kristen goaded Harwin into
attacking him but Kristen didn't fight
back Kristen just allowed Harwin to beat
the crap out of him which takes some
self-control given that Harwin is the
strongest man in the Seven Kingdoms and
Kristen just allows him to wail on him
without resisting
um so maybe you know I mean it's been 10
years maybe Kristen has learned a little
bit of self-control and learned a little
bit of restraint
um because yeah I mean Kristin cutting
out Luke's eye is something that he
probably wouldn't get away with I mean
people say people complain about like
it's crazy that Kristen got away with
murdering Joffrey lawnmuth at lano's
wedding
um I think it would be even less
acceptable for Kristen Cole to cut out
the the second in the line or third in
line to the throne
um I don't think Kristen would get away
with mutilating Luke in front of
everyone because Luke is much more you
know Highborn and much more important
than uh Joffrey lawnmuth was
thanks for the Super Chat from Grizzly
who says how can anyone claim C smoke if
Lenor is still alive that's an
interesting point because like in the
books uh Lenor is really dead as far as
we know I mean one of the themes of the
book Fire and Blood is that the history
books don't know everything and the
history books make mistakes so you know
I think it I think it nicely fits in the
sort of unreliable narrator theme of
Fire and Blood that
um
people
people might not be aware that lane or
actually secretly escaped but the thing
about dragons is that dragons only bond
with one human for their entire lifetime
you know
um so like vegar can have multiple
different writers he can have visenya
and then Balon and then Lana and now
amond but you can't have multiple living
targaryens bonded to the same Dragon at
the same time so you know if it is like
this whole magical thing you'd think
that since Lenor is still secretly alive
um maybe aemond should sorry since Lena
is still alive and still sea smoke was
uh lenor's dragon
maybe sea smoker can't bond to anyone
new because Lenor is still alive so that
so that raises the question of like is
there some like psychic connection that
transcends distance where like sea smoke
magically knows that Lenor is still
alive out there somewhere and therefore
no one can bond with sea smoke or maybe
as far as sea smoke knows lane or really
is dead so someone can bond with sea
smoke yeah I think that's a good and
interesting question and it also you
know it raises the point that lane or
abandoned his Dragon you know like
shaving off his Valyrian silver hair
he's not only giving up the appearance
of being Valyrian he's giving up his
Dragon sea smoke or maybe
um sea smoke will follow Lenor you know
like maybe sea smoke will seek lane or
out and will find it by some kind of
dragon magical Targaryen tracking GPS
you know maybe that Bond
um is too strong for lane or to leave
willingly or otherwise
um you know that's one of the things
that we're learning more about from this
show like in the books we don't know a
whole lot about how the Targaryen Dragon
connection works like we see a bit of it
with Daenerys and Her Dragons but
Daenerys is still working out how to
deal with her dragons like Daenerys is
not in good control over dragons in the
main books
and then in Fire and Blood like the
maesters don't know now how the
connection works either so um
so yeah it's cool that we're learning
more about these Mysteries and there are
a lot of open questions still
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Nick
who says Daemon and Rainier talk fire
but show Lenor real kindness
yeah that is that's an interesting
difference isn't it
um like I I thought it was interesting
how Rainier and Daemon they were talking
about how like fire is dangerous fire
consumes
um fire is this dangerous thing but then
they decide to get married to each other
uh so they embrace the the destructive
Targaryen fire despite how dangerous
Targaryen fire is like they talk in the
inside the episode about how there is
this real dangerous Chemistry Between
Daemon and rhaenyra like by embracing
each other I think they are embracing
the most sort of chaotic destructive
sides of themselves and they talk about
how rhaenyra marrying Daemon helps to
legitimize rhaenyra
um because
it combines rhaenyra's claim with
daemon's claim like remember like in
episode 1 Daemon was considered or at
least Daemon considered himself to be
the heir to the throne because he was
the brother of the king viserys
um so now when Daemon marries rhaenyra
that sort of combines daemon's claim
with rhaenyra's so it sort of makes
rhaenyra more of a legitimate
um heir to the throne arguably but we
also need to remember that in episode 1
a lot of people didn't want Daemon on
the throne and a lot of people were
worried that you know Daemon would rule
through rhaenyra even so like
and the fact that Daemon married
rhaenyra in some ways it makes rhaenyra
a better Heir and a stronger more
legitimate Heir but it also might make
people not want to support Rainier
because Daemon is there like Otto was
saying like we cannot let Daemon be king
we cannot let Daemon uh have influence
so some people might be less likely to
support Rainier and now thanks for the
Super Chat from Lucy the gamer who says
Lenor was awesome and amond finally got
a dragon thanks for the Super Chat from
Mick who says I can't imagine what the
kids must think as the only guests of
rhaenyra and daemond Daemon their
wedding I don't know what he's saying
there sick says Adam valarion is Lenor
oh uh well we're not going to spoil
anything in the future but that's that's
an interesting wild Theory thanks for
the Super Chat from dark Aurora thanks
for the Super Chat from Shane who says
Daemon and Rainier were trifling for
smashing at driftmark it seems like a
bad idea to have sex with your uncle on
a beach after after the wedding
as as Rainier and Daemon did did you
guys like the uh intimacy between day
one and rhaenyra I thought it was quite
creepy because you know Rainier was was
the one who initiated it rhaenyra was
saying that you know I have needs and I
want you uh practicing a lot of
affirmative consent here well done guys
um but I thought it was very creepy
given the context and like the history
with rhaenyra and Daemon because Daemon
is Rainier's uncle and Daemon has done
this like creepy intimate thing uh with
Rainier ever since she was a child
um he was very sort of close to her and
giving her gifts the word grooming has
been thrown around
um and then Daemon took his young niece
to a sex club and made out with her and
only stopped because he sort of found
himself unable whether physically or
morally it's a little ambiguous but you
know and you know that's how rainyra
discovered her sexuality was by macking
on her uncle
so you know I guess from that
perspective it makes sense you know
she's been trapped in this uh sexless
marriage with Lenor while banging Harwin
on the side but you know I it makes
sense that Rainier is attracted to
Daemon
um but I think that it's icky
because it's her uncle who knew her
since she was a kid yeah I guess this is
not a uh this is not a controversial
opinion I'm expressing here
I'm not breaking you ground by saying
this is icky but uh yeah it's also icky
with all of the sand that is in all of
their crevices right now uh like they
just put their clothes back on and just
went back anyway let's move on from the
incest thanks for the Super Chat from
coconut who says why wasn't it a big
deal that amond took Vega it is a big
deal that aemond took Vega for sure I
mean well yeah I mean they should have
talked about it at this confrontation
scene yeah I agree with you coconut I
always agree with the coconut
um yeah they should have like they were
really angry about aemond losing an eye
but they also should have been really
angry about hey guys this child just
took the biggest weapon of war in the
world this is kind of a big deal I think
that's an issue throughout the show like
I think that they should be talking more
about what valuable critical assets
these dragons are and who owns them is
an entirely big deal and I feel like
they should be talking about Verma Thor
and Silverwing like I've put them on
this chart because they are two of the
biggest oldest strongest dragons in the
world and like who controls them is a
big deal
and especially now that like the battle
lines are being drawn I think that
everyone should be really thinking about
who controls these powerful weapons uh
as the conflict gets worse because I
think it's very clear right now that
this conflict is getting worse not
better and there's only going to be more
violence between these two sides
so yeah I agree with you coconut I think
the ownership of Vega should be a big
deal and and I think you know they
raised some interesting questions in
this scene
um where Rayna and Baylor were saying
like hey we have a right to this Dragon
because that was our mother's Dragon so
aemon should not be allowed to take Vega
um but amond is like well you know Vega
was up for grabs Lena was dead and and
aemond rejected the idea that Baylor and
Reina have some special ownership and
that's another thing that you know it's
not really clear in the books like who
gets access to which dragons like some
of the dragons are on Dragonstone some
of the dragons are in the dragon pit
vegar was apparently just like hanging
out on the beach just like just like
retired
um until Lena and then aemond took her
out of retirement so yeah there's a lot
of like legitimate open questions about
like who gets dragons and who controls
dragons and so uh yeah I hope that
they'll talk about that more in the
future sure
um thanks for the Super Chat from minute
who says they aren't trying to make
aemon bloodraven right
yeah so so there is a character uh in
the books called bloodraven
um and bloodraven is born years and
years Generations after
um
this whole story in House of the Dragon
um and you know bloodraven originally
did have two eyes so um so no aemond
Targaryen is not bloodraven uh but
bloodraven is this extremely cool
character uh in the Duncan egg uh
prequels and then bloodraven later
becomes uh the three-eyed Raven or the
three-eyed Crow who teaches bran about
magic and yeah like bloodraven is is
missing an eye because the eye was cut
out by bitter steel who was bloodraven's
half-brother
um and they got into a bit of a spat
over
um who got to hook up with their Mutual
half-sister Sierra sea star uh so it was
this whole it was this whole other
Targaryen Civil War that was also
largely about incest and and stuff but
this is like long after the dragons were
gone this is this is later so so no
bloodraven is not aemond but bloodraven
is a very cool character
thanks for the Super Chat from sod who
says viserys was born 77 AC Lena died
120 AC so viserys Targaryen is 43. yeah
okay thanks for the clarification we
don't know exactly what year it is in
um House of the Dragon like they're
switching around the orders of events I
mean yeah well this is the year of the
red spring so you know I guess it should
be 120 AC the year of the red spring is
is the year that everything goes
terribly wrong it's the year that aemond
loses his eye Lena valarion dies Elena
of valerion dies Harwin strong and
Lionel strong die
that's the year the red spring and yeah
it's when everything starts to go
dramatically downhill
um we already talked about leonor's
Dragon uh sea smoke and yeah it's
possible that someone could now claim
Leno's Dragon sea smoke or maybe since
Lenor is still alive maybe you see smoke
will go and follow Lenor to the east or
maybe sea smoke will not bond with
anyone else uh it's an open question
thanks for the Super Chat from CC uh
Team crabs team celtagar sends their
regards I have to admit that when this
show was announced I was disappointed
but I could not have been more wrong
love the new wedding tradition yeah so
they did this whole like ancient
Valyrian blood ceremony in the marriage
of Daemon and rhaenyra and I enjoyed
this like I really enjoy like one of the
things that they're emphasizing in this
show
is that uh Daemon and is that the
targaryens are very connected to their
Valyrian Heritage especially uh Daemon
is like very enthusiastic about it he's
like a lopper big big history buff who
loves his uh genealogy in a creepy
amount because like remember like the
valyrians were horrible like the
valyrians were a slave Empire who like
conquered half the world
um in the in their hunger for for slaves
until they blew up
um the valyrians were like not great and
yet uh viserys has his whole little
Warhammer model Railway uh diorama of
how much he he loves valyria and Daemon
wants to emulate the valyrians like he
was talking earlier about polygamy and
stuff like the valyrians like avalirian
forebears
and they say in the books that all
Valyrian sorcery is based on blood or
fire
um and so in this wedding we we see both
we see that there's blood on the candles
or maybe they're just red candles I hope
those are just red candles because
that's a lot of blood
um but you know rain but Daemon and
rhaenyra they both cut themselves with
dragon glass or obsidian which is the um
which is the volcanic stone that can
um that can kill White Walkers and so
yeah I think it is very appropriate that
the valyrians use Dragon glass to cut
themselves to make a blood Bond and it
makes this marriage between uh Rainier
and Daemon feel very real and very
significant
um so
yeah it's almost like this is Rainier's
Real Marriage you know like the lane or
thing was not all that meaningful to her
it did not produce children they weren't
really you know romantically in love
this this bond between Daemon and
rhaenyra is like the real magical
lifelong type thing
um
mineth thanks for the Super Chat yeah we
just discussed um amond and bloodraven
that a modern bloodraven are not the
same character uh thanks for the Super
Chat from Atri who says I like how
nobody other than Otto cares that amond
claimed Vega yeah it's silly it should
be a big deal that anyone claimed Vega
especially now that war seems to be
approaching thanks for the Super Chat
from Dustin who says it seems to me that
Leno and Carl escaping together was the
plan yeah I think it was Rainier and
daemon's plan to let Lena and Carl
Escape I thought at first that maybe
Rainier genuinely wanted lane or dead
but uh it looks like she actually
allowed her husband to escape to Freedom
thanks for the Super Chat from James who
says so Lenor valerion was the last son
alive yeah so rainey's Targaryen and
Corliss valerion had two kids Elena and
Lena
Elena died trying to give birth and
Lenor has now seemingly died
um killed seemingly by his lover Carl
um and so it's been a pretty bad year
for rhaenys and Corliss losing both of
their children uh in short succession
and I enjoyed this scene between callus
and rhaenys
um before the death of Lenor where
they're discussing Carlos's ambition and
rainy says basically the same thing that
she said
um previously when she was saying hey
call us like I don't care about the
throne I don't want the throne I'm over
it
um because like I want a valerion on the
throne he wants his grandchildren Jace
and Luke to inherit the throne even
though he knows that they are not really
his children by Blood because they're
actually harwin's children not Lena's
children but Corliss has this nice line
about how history does not remember
blood it remembers names which is true
like it's true in Real History like some
people there are lots of real historical
figures where we don't know for sure who
banged who but we do know their name and
we do know their accomplishments and we
do know their history so you know you
can leave a legacy you can your name can
be passed on even if you aren't actually
connected by Blood
um so we have this moment between callus
and
um lucerus valerion because the idea is
that Rainier is first-born son Jace will
inherit the throne after rhaenyra
whereas her second son lucerus will
inherit driftmark and high tide he will
be the new Lord of house valarion and
kolis Embraces that even though Luke is
not his child they look nothing alike
but but Corliss is willing to embrace
that and I think that is why uh Daemon
chuckled during his wife's funeral which
was like oh my God Daemon you [ __ ]
because like vemond is making this
speech about our blood must never thin
and then Daemon Chuckles which is like
the most disrespectful thing to do at
your own wife's funeral [ __ ] hell
um but he laughs and I think he laughs
because
the Valerian blood has been thinned it's
been thinned in the sense that Jace and
Luke the supposed children of lane or
valerion are actually the children of
Harwin strong so in that sense the
Valyrian blood of house valerion has
been watered down by introducing Harwin
because the whole idea is that the
targaryens and presumably the valerions
they mostly marry within their own
family family to preserve their Valyrian
Dragon riding blood they don't want
other families to get their dragon
riding genes and they don't want any
other family's non-dragon writing genes
getting into their own bloodline
so so you know by accepting lucerus
valerion as his Heir callus is like
allowing his family's blood to be
watered down but but I guess like in the
case of the valerians the valerians are
not Dragon Riders like Lena and Elena of
valerion are Dragon Riders because they
are the children of rhaeny's Targaryen
because the targaryens have dragon
riding blood but the valerions don't so
like I guess that might be why Carlos is
cool with it but like you know surely
call us would want to preserve Lena and
lenor's blood because they are Dragon
Riders so if Corliss wants his family to
have dragons he should not be supporting
Jace and Luke or Luke being his Heir he
should be supporting Baylor being his
Heir because that's what rhaenys says in
this scene Rainey says that like hey I
don't want you to make luceris valarion
heir to driftmark I want you to make
Baylor Targaryen air to driftmark
because Baylor is actually our blood
Baylor is actually
cordless and rhaenys's grandchild unlike
Luke
so rhaenys is supporting the candidate
who actually is a dragon rider I feel
like they should be talking about this
stuff like I guess maybe it feels like
icky to talk about like you know Gene
selection uh and such but um yeah it is
very significant like who will inherit
driftmark and will that person be a
dragon rider or not will that person be
of callus valarion's blood or just of
his name all interesting questions
um
the last of the valerians yeah that's a
good point galadorn in the live chat
since I mean by Blood you know Jason
Luke have the Valerian name but not the
Valerian blood
um well I mean you say the last of the
valerians vemond valerion is still alive
um and vemond in this episode was very
conspicuously wearing uh some very fancy
valerion regalia vemond was giving the
speech and and he's very conspicuously
wearing the valerion crest so so no like
Baylor and Reina aren't the last
valerians I think I think vemond is
positioning himself as the last valerion
and since it's since it's vemon
specifically talking about the
importance of valerian blood and not
watering it down I think vemond is
positioning himself as saying like hey
I've got Pure Valerian blood so uh we
will see how that develops
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Goat
Who says Dear Rainier and Daemon get
married right after Elena supposedly
died yes which is considered a party
Foul
um they talk in the books about how
everybody's outraged that uh Daemon and
Rainier are marry right after both of
their respective spouses died daemon's
wife Lena just died rhaenyra's husband
Lena just died and yet these guys are
instantly getting married and and you
know they didn't ask anyone's permission
to get married like you're meant to have
the king's blessing if you're gonna
marry Royal people like this
um so this is just their own thing by
the way I I like that this Valyrian
priest guy has this like glyph on his
chest I don't know what that glyph is
meant to represent specifically I guess
it's something Valerian but like I enjoy
that they've got their own thing going
on here like who is this guy like is he
a priest of some Valyrian religion like
in the books they talk talk about the
valyrians worshiping many different gods
the the names
um you know maraxis and Cyrax those are
the names of Valyrian Gods so like there
is a like Valyrian religion or multiple
Valyrian religions I wonder if this guy
is a priest of some Valyrian religion
alongside the religion of the faith of
the seven and the faith of the old gods
it's um it's cool to see this stuff like
this is the kind of sort of magical
world-building cultural law that the
books are full of but the original Game
of Thrones show did not show much of
this stuff and I really like our house
of the Dragon is embracing that that
World building and that magic and all
that good nerdy stuff that makes the
books so much fun uh people in the live
chat are asking what happened to mazaria
yeah so mazaria was the former lover of
Daemon
um and viserys ordered uh viserys
ordered Daemon to get rid of her
um and we saw that the relationship
between Missouri and Daemon seems to
have broken down in episode four like
mazaria gives Daemon a place to crash
but mazaria also like tells Otto through
her spies
um that
Daemon hooked up with rainy era so it
seems that mizaria might have actually
been working against Daemon in episode
four
um and mazaria has now established
herself as yeah like a spymaster working
for Otto so I you know it's been 10
years since then so we don't know what
mazaria is up to now maybe she's become
even more powerful in the intervening
years or maybe she's decided to you know
leave maybe go back East uh considering
how Bloody things are getting in
Westeros uh it might be a good idea to
do what Elena and Carl did so yeah it'll
be interesting to see if mazario returns
and what her relationship to Daemon to
Otto might be uh Christian in Super Chat
says where is dayron Targaryen um
yeah so you know I I don't want to spoil
anything but um uh I I mean I will note
that in the opening sequence to the show
for the past couple of episodes
um there have been four uh rivers of
blood coming from Alison Hightower not
three
um so yeah I don't think it's a spoiler
like like at this point uh Alison and
viserys actually have four children
probably like they haven't confirmed it
yet officially
um but see how there are four
bloodstreams coming from Allison I I
feel like this opening sequence is not
very good if I'm being honest like it's
meant to be a symbolic representation of
the children but like you can't tell
who's who like most people can't easily
tell who's who on this symbolic tree but
there are four bloodstreams suggesting
that there are four children
um of Allison and viserys and so I think
what's happening is that that fourth
child uh dayron Targaryen might be
fostered in Old Town currently and we
might see him later because they've
never said yeah they've never confirmed
either way so I think we'll see daeron
later so uh there will probably be an
additional child
added alongside aegon Helena and amond a
bit later on
um thanks for the Super Chat from Maro
who says Otto is a terrible person and
grandfather he's causing the conflict
yeah I thought that scene was a lot of
fun when like Alison
attacks princess Rainier
and then her dad comes in and says like
yo it reminds it reminds me of the bit
when Daenerys comes home in Game of
Thrones season six like remember when
like Daenerys like went off into the
Dothraki sea
um and uh and then Tyrion and like Dario
and and gray worm were left to sort of
hold the fort and then everything went
catastrophically wrong and then in
season six episode eight like Daenerys
said like hey kids I'm home like what
happened in the meantime and then Tyrion
has to explain that yeah that like yeah
everything everything went horrifically
wrong
um sorry Daenerys
um I I got a similar Vibe when Otto
walked in uh and Allison was like oh
yeah sorry Dad sorry I attacked the
princess I I did wrong I I I'll I'll go
on time out
um But Otto contrary to Alison's
expectations was actually quite proud of
Allison like he was actually smiling
when he said oh I've never seen that
side of you before Alison uh you know
you clearly have the determination to
win this game look at him smiling his
daughter just attacked the princess and
demanded a child to have his eye cut out
and Otto is smiling so yeah like I agree
Mara that Otto is a pretty horrible dude
he is encouraging this conflict to get
worse Otto is not interested in peace he
wants this conflict
and so I think that you know that that
clarifies you know like when Otto was
talking to Alice and in episode five
um Otto was saying like conflict is
inevitable like war will follow if
Rainier takes the throne Rainier will
try to kill your children and it's like
well hang on a minute maybe that's a
self-fulfilling prophecy like Otto is
saying that oh there will inevitably be
conflict but maybe the conflict is only
happening because Otto and people like
Otto
um are causing the conflict to happen
and then you know Alison passed this
message down to her son aegon and said
like hey aegon there will be conflict
Rainier will try to kill you but like
that that only is true because Alison
and others are making this conflict
worse so yeah I think you can make the
argument that Otto and Alison and others
are largely responsible for making this
conflict happen because you know that
they're encouraging it they're embracing
it
Otto is uh not a great guy
um everyone in the live chat is saying
hashtag tag why Matt thanks minneth and
I don't know why are we talking about
Matt Smith Matt Damon as he's known
anyway uh thanks for the Super Chat from
a latinu who says how does Kristen Cole
Crush Joffrey lawnmith's head in but the
strongest Knight Harwin strong barely
phases him
yeah I mean I don't love it when people
punch people in the head multiple times
and there's no lasting damage like one
of the worst was in the Battle of the
bastards in the original Game of Thrones
show when Jon Snow punched Ramsay in the
face like I think it was like 30 times
or something
um I think if you did that your hand
would be broken all your fingers would
be broken and the other person would be
dead uh and in in the previous episode
Harwin came and punched Kristen in the
head about a dozen times uh well maybe
just like six I don't know I didn't
count but Harwin is supposed to be the
strongest man alive I mean I guess you
know I maybe Harwin was not punching him
as hard as he possibly could because
yeah then Kristen would be dead
um but
yeah I agree it's kind of dumb
um I mean yeah Kristen should probably
have some pretty serious head injuries
maybe he does maybe Kristen did sustain
some brain injuries in that beating and
maybe that explains Kristen making uh
poor decisions now and in the future
uh thanks to the Super Chat from Kate
who says do you think Alison is supposed
to be hotter
um yeah Alison is described as being hot
but I don't know seems kind of rude to
speculate on real human beings
attractiveness thanks for the Super Chat
from Mick who says I can't imagine what
the children think uh Daemon and
Rainier's wedding yeah that's true so uh
at the wedding of Daemon and Rainier uh
rhaenyra's Sons Jace and Luke and the uh
cousins Baylor and Raina we're just sort
of watching this Blood Magic Ritual and
yeah this this face the facial
expression is exactly how I was feeling
too
um watching them like share blood
because they they cut their body on
their lips and on their hands and then
they like smushed their open wounds
together like I don't think that is
covered safe guys uh that was gross and
weird and the kids are uh yeah looking
appropriately Disturbed
um thanks for the Super Chat from
blastwave who says love the channel Nate
and Katie says hi thanks for the Super
Chat from Dev who says
the child fight was mad on comfy yeah I
mean we talked about how that I mean
that feels like the natural result of
all of the training and all of the all
of the words that were said by the
parents like they were telling each
other you should be enemies and here's
how to fight so it's like not surprising
that this happened really
um
#blame the parents
uh yeah we talked about uh Rainier and
Daemon thanks Alchemist thanks for the
Super Chat from Nick who says Rainier is
also a dragon of three heads three false
Sons three lovers three betrayals the
Symmetry between her and Daenerys is
unreal and tragic yeah I mean George
uses a lot of the same tropes and a lot
of the same ideas in his Westeros
stories yeah there certainly are
parallels between rangiora and Daenerys
like I mean both of them are people who
try to claim what is rightfully theirs
I.E the iron throne and they feel like a
lot of people are against them and a lot
of people are against them and people
betray them
um and
they sometimes indulge in violence that
they really shouldn't because they are
Targaryen Dragon Riders who have that
sort of fiery energy and sometimes they
lash out but um I thought rhaenyra was
relatively quite restrained I mean I
think in this episode it was more Alison
who was lashing out violently while
rhaenyra was the one who was composed
you know like rhaeniro when Ellison was
attacking her with that Valyrian blade
rhaenyra was just saying well now they
see how you really are
um she was holding back and I thought
you know I mean it is a change from
the books that they use this Valerian
steel catspaw dagger uh that's the one
that Alison attacks rhaenyra with
um and in the show uh this catapult
dagger is the one that Arya uses to kill
the night King and end the long night
and in the show aegon has engraved the
prophecy of The Song of Ice and Fire
about the white walkers onto the blade
itself so like the blade as visera says
is a symbol of the importance of the
targaryens being unified and strong in
order to save the world from the white
walkers so it's it's wonderfully you
know it's a wonderful juxtaposition that
this dagger that is meant to symbolize
you know unity and the sacred
responsibility of
um the targaryens is instead used for
division and infighting and I love that
the dagger drops to the ground as though
you know like Alison drops the dagger to
the ground as though this responsibility
is being dropped the targaryens are
failing to uphold their sacred
responsibility to be unified and to try
and save the world from the white
walkers I thought it was interesting
that it was then Kristen Cole who picked
up the dagger
um this this magic prophetic cat spa
blade is picked up by Kristen Cole maybe
that's meaningless
but um why is he the guy with the dagger
maybe it's going to be significant who
has it like I would think that Kristen
would give it back to viserys surely
because it's because it's viserys's
dagger but I wonder who will take up the
dagger next
I mean maybe Rainier will take up the
dagger because she's the one who knows
about the prophecy and you know viserys
passed it on to her but yeah kind of
weird to me that Kristen has it probably
not a big deal anyway
um thanks for the Super Chat from mineth
who is asking Matt why for some reason
thanks for the Super Chat from mutt who
says any significance to the Valyrian
steel knife having no blood yeah that
that is true like like we did see in uh
in this shot we see when Alison drops
the knife there's no blood on the knife
even though Allison just slashed Rainier
as wrist with the blade I don't know
maybe maybe Valyrian steel is uh
moisture wicking and it simply rolls
right off I I don't know there are um I
like how you can see sort of like the
folds and like the the waviness in the
texture of the blade
um apparently that's like a real world
kind of Steel called Damascus steel
which is a special ancient kind of Steel
that is extra strong and light because
Valerian steel is extra strong and light
and uh is better for making weapons with
but the secret of making Valyrian steel
is now lost no one knows how the
valyrians made the Valyrian steel
um there are some fellas like tobo Mott
who know how to reforge the steel and
that's how viserys sorry that's how
Tywin Lannister melts down ice and turns
it into oath keeper and widow's whale
but no one knows how to make new
Valyrian steel so there's about like 200
known Valyrian steel blades in Westeros
currently in the time of the main series
but no one knows how to make more so
they are these very precious artifacts
thanks for the Super Chat from Kevin who
says I was hoping Carl would actually
kill Lenor and then Daemon would ride
karaxi's and set fire to Carl's ship to
wrap it up I feel like a fire from a
dragon is one of the more conspicuous
ways to murder Carl
um but yeah I mean that that's that's
basically how it sounds in the book like
in the books it is a mystery what
happened with Carl and Lena everyone
thinks that Carl killed Leno
um but it is suggested that maybe Daemon
paid Carl to kill lanor because Daemon
wanted to marry rhaenyra
which again in itself is a little bit
different because in this episode it is
rhaenyra who initiates sex with Daemon
and it is Rainier who proposes marriage
to Daemon
um it's interesting like Daemon has
become more passive Daemon has like sort
of like he's more sort of standing back
like in previous episodes Daemon was
always trying to bring attention to
himself like he like I love the scene
when Daemon like walks in with the crown
of the stepstones and Daemon is trying
to say everyone look at me like he had
that whole tantrum in Dragonstone where
he like stole the dragon egg and he
declared that he was marrying mazaria
and it was it was just a tantrum look at
me look at me and then he like you know
he risks his life to single-handedly
kill the crab feeder and then he takes
the crown and gives the hammer and drops
it on the ground add it to the others
Daemon is just screaming for attention
before the 10-year time skip but now
like maybe you know maybe you know away
Elena valarion his wife did change
Daemon a bit like maybe she did mellow
him out maybe you know and and I don't
think that'll last like what I think is
that Daemon marrying rhaenyra might be a
return to fiery Targaryen chaotic
Behavior like the the Fire and Blood
uniting with rhaeny era I think they
will make each other more dangerous more
violent more chaotic whereas for the
last couple of episodes Daemon has been
relatively reserved and has been
allowing other people to be
um crazy and violent yeah he became a
dad maybe becoming a dad you know
Mellows him out
maybe hey look at me uh Mr demon
um thanks for the Super Chat from Harold
who says that episode 7 says that
rhaenyra is good and Alison is bad yeah
I agree that that's how it comes off
like Alison I think comes off as clearly
a villain here because she attacked
rhaenyra with a dagger and she tried to
cut out Luke's eye which is like that
that is Cersei Behavior she was behaving
like Cersei in Game of Thrones episode
2.
so Allison I think does come off as as a
monster here I mean you know I mean in
her defense Allison has just seen her
own child have her eye cut out and I
think many parents would react intensely
uh in response to their child being
mutilated like I I think you would get
very emotional and angry uh if your
child had their eye cut out with a
dagger I personally have gotten very
upset in the occasions when my children
have had their eyes cut out so I can
relate to Alice and here
um but yeah I do agree that elephant
comes off as more villainous than
Rainier I hear
um and so one of the sort of constant
questions here one of the constant
things to think about is like are we
siding with rhaenyra or are we siding
with Alice and who is the hero who is
the villain and you know it is meant to
be a morally complicated story but
sometimes some person will see better
some sometimes someone will will say bad
um anyway thanks for the Super Chat from
Kevin and thanks for the Super Chat from
I am lavam uh who sides with Alison
Auto is a g I feel like Alison got
worried about strong because he seems to
be a loose cannon what do you think
uh well there are no strongs alive
anymore unless you count Jason Luke and
Joffrey I think you mean that Alison was
worried about Kristen
not sure what you mean thanks for the
Super Chat from default who says kind of
disappointed with the lack of Valyrian
Dragon law besides the wedding this
episode yeah I would like to see more
discussion of the Dragons I mean look we
got to see Amon amond claim Vega like
that was extremely cool I like the sort
of communication almost between amond
and Vega and I loved how Veigar looked I
mean it was very dark like like a lot of
these bloody TV shows you need to you
need to turn up your brightness in order
to be able to see what's going on in
these dark scenes but I think Vegas like
appearance was wonderful and I loved how
Vega was clearly just this you know old
grandma just having a nap on the beach
and Vega is sad that Lena died like in
the books they mention
um
oh yeah Lara's strong yeah I'm sorry I
will get back to that but I like how
they mentioned in the books that you
know Vega is upset because uh his writer
Lena has just died like Vega is in
mourning you know Vega had to put up
with the death of Balon had to put up
with the death of vicenya and now Vega
has lost another Rider so
in the books they say that vegar is
especially grumpy
um and Vega's grumpiness makes it
dangerous for aemond to come and try and
claim her
um and when vega got angry at being
woken up like any grandma would uh Vega
like even you know got ready to breathe
fire on aemond like she was charging up
her lasers but then aemon stood firm and
just like Chris Pratt in Jurassic world
uses the hand holds up his hand like
Crocodile Dundee to say no don't kill me
and used Valyrian commands and then
vegar accepted aemond and Vega was also
like sniffing at amond like we saw Vega
like like getting a good getting a good
whiff of amond and I and I think that
that might be vegar smelling the
Targaryen jeans in amond and going like
yeah okay like you passed the sniff test
therefore you can claim me you are a
real Targaryen of Valyrian blood and
because yeah like a dry Dragon would not
allow a non-targaryen or someone without
Targaryen Dragon riding blood to claim
them so I enjoyed that
um but yeah uh I am lavam was talking
about Lara strong being a loose cannon
yeah so I mean in the previous episode
Alison was horrified that Lara strong
killed his father Lionel and his brother
Harwin
um she was like I did not wish for you
to murder Harwin and Lionel so I agree
that Alison is a bit scared of Laris and
you've got Laris like sort of leering at
Alison from across the funeral which is
just so awkward and weird
um but I think Alison also recognizes
that blarus is useful because Laris was
saying that like hey like I can get [ __ ]
done like you need an eye I've got an
eye guy like I can accomplish [ __ ] and
like I think Alison is scared of what
larus might be capable of but you know
especially after being encouraged by
Otto earlier I think Allison is starting
to accept that like this is going to be
a violent bad situation so having a
violent bad dude like Mike Laris at her
side seems useful and you know I think
that by using Laris Allison is playing
with fire and I think that she
understands that on some level but um I
think she knows that she might have to
use him she says that you know I need
someone who can use discretion so um
yeah thanks for the Super Chat from
Mustang
who says you're my favorite YouTuber and
your videos help me sleep I feel like
the pacing was weird but the ending made
my jaw drop this episode thanks Mustang
um yeah the piece well yeah I agree that
pacing did feel a bit weird because like
there was a lot of everyone just
standing around looking at each other
significantly like there was a lot of
sort of funerals standing around and
then there was a lot of like post
funerals standing around and then you
know like there was a lot of sort of
like slow conversational moments and
then it was like whoa children fight uh
mutilation Dragon ride and then back to
this slow brooding thing so yeah that
might feel a bit weird the pacing thanks
for the super jet from bifong who says
what are your thoughts on the general
Vibes doing the potential of the story
Justice
I think they are doing the story Justice
yeah I mean you got to remember that the
book Fire and Blood is very uh short
like like this entire season of TV so
far has taken place within one chapter
in The Fire and Blood book The Fire and
Blood book doesn't have any detail it
doesn't have any dialogue or almost no
dialogue it's just like on this year
this happened and on this year that
happened so you know given that the Bare
Bones that they have I think that
they've done a fantastic job of like
adding some Flesh and Bones to that
skeleton and you know they've made some
interesting choices like you know
letting Lenor and Carl escape and live
free but um I think that that's a good
decision I think you know some people
might dislike that particular change
um but I think it's interesting because
like this the book is about like the
historians don't know everything weird
stuff happens that the historians don't
find out about and I think this is the
sort of difference that there is I mean
also like Lena valerion's death last
episode like her choosing to die by dry
Dragon was I think like a cool and
interesting change and that's better and
more interesting than just Lena dying in
childbirth or dying after childbirth as
she did in the books
I mean I think one change that is
disappointing is that in the in the
books Elena and Daemon were on driftmark
for some time with the kids Baylor and
trainer and uh rhaenyra was on
Dragonstone and so rhaenyra became close
friends with Lena valarion and with
Daemon and they used to ride their
dragons together and their kids got to
hang out
um so there was these like years of
closeness between Rainier's family and
daemon's family in the books that we
didn't get in the show and I think
that's a shame so some people even ship
Rainier and Lena because it's said in
the books that rhaenyra is Fond and more
than fond of Lana and some people got
some sort of like
um Vibes that rhaenyra may have had a
crush on Alison when they were kids when
they were teenagers under the weirwood
tree they were quite intimate so some
people reckon that Rainier might be
bisexual there's no you know there's not
a lot of profile by the way in Fire and
Blood but um yeah it's a shame that we
didn't I mean just in general it would
have been good to see more of Lena
valerion she's she's an important
character
um but we we don't get to learn much
about her apart from her sort of brief
moments in the previous episode
thanks for the Super Chat from Daniel
who says do you consider the expansions
in the show to be actual changes or more
so explanations of vague events yeah I
mean look there's no official absolute
Canon like that like you know like
George Martin said in a recent interview
with history of Westeros and you should
all go and check out the history of
Westeros YouTube channel and podcast
which is one of the great uh Song of Ice
and Fire content creators but they got
to interview George and George said like
when Aziz and Australia were questioning
George about issues of Canon and what is
real and what is what is true and what
is false and George said like hey guys
like I make this [ __ ] up like there's no
official Canon like that all they're
doing is telling good stories
um so I don't think we should worry too
much about you know is this a retcon is
this official is this historical
inaccuracy it's like yeah those are all
themes but I don't think there's only
one true real
truth of what happened because uh
spoiler it didn't actually happen
thanks for the Super Chat from boy
brushed blue who says the shot of
rhaenyra zoning out during the during
the bumping bits scene looks similar to
Alison and viserys in bed that is an
interesting interpretation
um I personally did not notice Rainier
is zoning out I'll have to re-watch it I
I mostly was just
um cringing at the thought of all the
sand that they were boning on
um I thought it I thought I thought we
were meant to read that scene as like
some real genuine intimacy that they
were both enjoying I mean they probably
wouldn't have gotten married if Rainier
had had a bad time during that love
making but yeah people's interpretations
might vary there
um thanks for the Super Chat from Andrew
Taubman and from the cat files who said
really I wish you spelled files the
other way cat files really enjoyed the
interaction between rhaenyra and
daemon's kiddos this episode hope we see
them become closer next week yeah yeah
there was this little moment where
rhaenyra came up to Jace and was like
hey you should go and be nice to Baylor
and Reina
because they just lost their mother and
they are your cousins and so you should
be good to Baylor and Rayna and so they
had a little moment where Jace went over
and and held held their hands held
Baylor or rain in his hand
um and you know we talked in the
previous video about how Baylor and
Rayna it's not sort of clear what the
place in this world is because they grew
up in pentos like Daemon said that
pentos is our home
um so it's like you know will Baylor and
Reina fit in on driftmark will they stay
on driftmark what's their deal who are
these kids
um
it seems as though they were close with
rhaeny's Targaryen their Grandma
um so maybe they do know each other
maybe they have spent some time together
it's not really clear what their deal is
but it'll be interesting to find out
thanks for the Super Chat from Judith
who says is Laris in love with Alison
yeah he has he has this sort of hungry
look to him like he looks like he wants
Alison for sure but like does he want
her romantically does he want her
sexually or does he just want her
politically like I think it's very clear
that Laris is trying to manipulate
Alison like in the previous episode
he was very much saying that like you
owe me you know
um
so I I think that Laris wants Alison for
political Advantage as much or more as
he wants her romantically but that could
be part of it as well I mean look Larice
is living in a world where men like him
are tend to be valued for their physical
prowess and Laris was the brother the
little brother of Harwin breakbones
strong one of the most celebrated
knights in Westeros the strongest
handsomest dude who was so hot that he
could you know he could convince the
princess and the heir of the realm to
cheat with him like that's how like hot
and successful Harwin was so perhaps
Laris felt resentful and left out and
and you know maybe he's an angry incel
maybe he's like angry that he feels
rejected and so maybe that's part of
what's going on with him uh you know
with his club foot and stuff maybe he
was teased for that maybe he feels like
aemond like amond was bullied and feels
like punched down on and so when he gets
Vega he's on this power trip and he's
really excited to have power and he
wants to sort of punish the people who
made fun of him like there's a sense of
that from aemond I think this episode so
maybe Laris has like a similar Vibe he
wants power to sort of show everyone
that he's good and tough even though
he's got a wonky leg
um which again I think yeah that is
quite similar to uh
that is quite similar to Littlefinger
blue milks feels bad for rhaenys yeah
yeah there's a line in the books about
how uh call us and rainy it's like you
know like the year of a red spring was a
bad year for everyone for a lot of
people
um and everyone had reason to tear their
clothes into mourn and to be upset but
no one had more reason to be upset than
rainys and clawless because they lost
both of their children in one year
so it's a dark day
thanks for the Super Chat from Isis who
says since Vega is quite old don't you
think she might die pretty soon
yeah I mean dragons can die of old age
because balerion the black dread died
shortly after King viserys claimed
valerion like viserys rode balerion like
once or twice and then balerion died
because valerion was hundreds of years
old going back to valyria like centuries
old and vegar is a vegar is now like 170
years old or something
uh we have her actual birthday in the
book which is nice so if you want to
celebrate Vega's birthday you can get a
little dragon birthday cake maybe a
ghost with a candle on its head that
would be an appropriate birthday cake
for a dragon so yeah like Vega might I
mean I mean they do say in the books
that Veigar is slowing down like she's
very sleepy and slow compared to how she
used to be but she is still powerful
when she gets angry
um just like many Grandmas so yeah I
mean yeah maybe Vega will die soon
suddenly she's slowing down maybe she'll
start forgetting people's names a little
bit like viserys mistakenly called
Alison by Emma's name maybe I mean maybe
Vega is uh you know starting to get some
Dragon dementia maybe Vega thinks that
aemond is vicenia or is or is Balon I
saw a funny meme about like it's a meme
with like someone taking their Grandma
out of the retirement home and it's like
oh is that you for sending you are we
conquering dawn again like she's the
sort of daughtery old lady
um Vega is wonderful and I hope that she
doesn't die soon
thanks for the Super Chat from Nick and
well yeah to talk a little bit more
about dragons like uh dragons they talk
in the books about how the older a
dragon gets the bigger it gets and the
tougher it gets
um like the scales of a dragon Harden as
the dragon gets older and so uh an old
adult Dragon can't even be pierced by
like arrows and Scorpion bolts and stuff
like those scales like almost impossible
to to Break
um one of the only things that can kill
an adult dragon is another adult Dragon
like we saw that in the reign of maegor
uh King maegor the cruel killed his
nephew aegon the uncrowned and his
Dragon Quicksilver with uh balerion so
dragons can kill dragons
um and dragons are very tough in their
older age and I think their fires grow
stronger as well so
yeah
um Jess in the live chat says maraxis
was quite young then yeah well maraxis
is an exception because maraxis was the
dragon of uh rhaeny's Targaryen who was
the sister wife of aegon the Conqueror
and maraxis died in Dawn because the
dornish shot a scorpion bolt into
miraxi's eye so that was that sort of
like you know freak chance thing that it
managed to hit moraxi's eyes
specifically so it bypassed all of
maraxi's tough scales and just went
right into a little dragon brain so uh
that can happen too look it's Game of
Thrones No One Is Safe anything can
happen
um yeah thanks for the Super Chat from
Nick who says no matter what you think
about amond you have to give him credit
for having the biggest balls in Westeros
yeah aemond Amon stood firm even when
the biggest monster in the world was
like threatening to burn him
um I like how Vega has like these ropes
all over Vega's body which is like
rigging because like how else could you
attach Saddles and luggage and people
without some rigging
uh aemond almost fell off Veigar while
while he was going on the joyride uh
amond forgot to uh connect himself to
Vega by a chain which I think is how
it's usually done you don't want to fall
off a dragon when you're flying around
like that but the whole dragonflight
sequence was was really fun like I like
how it felt dangerous and and wild and
you know it's all very you know it
doesn't it doesn't feel at all realistic
the way that you know he's like clicking
on when he's being flung around but you
know it's a dragon it's a dragonflight I
feel like this dragonflight was more fun
than the dragonflights in Game of
Thrones like we got some with Daenerys
and even with Jon but um this one had a
lot of sort of dynamism to it some like
fun angles and like swooping over the
water and like the birds and I I really
liked how Vega looked like he was above
the clouds
um earlier during the funeral just like
this shadow on the clouds I was like I I
thought there's a lot of interesting
Dragon cinematography going on in this
show which we uh didn't get so much of
in the original show
um it was also cool just seeing the
sheer number of dragons that arrived on
driftmark that's one two three four five
in that shot alone in the books they say
that there were so many dragons on
driftmark that it was like drift Market
to become a second Valeria
um which is you know that speaks to
Targaryen power that they have so many
dragons but it also was a bit ominous
because valyria fell valyria was
destroyed in the Doom so like being like
valyria is not necessarily a good thing
and I think that's part of why you know
this Valyrian model city is like the one
of the central symbols in this show
um because the targaryens are so
obsessed with their history like you
know Daemon and rhaenyra have this
Valyrian wedding but over all of these
constant like connections to valyria is
looming the fall of valyria and the
inevitability of of death and failure
and collapse so I think we should be uh
mindful of those themes when we're
looking at all of these dragons on
driftmark
thanks for the Super Chat from Elijah
who says aemond seemed like his nephews
and aegon outside the bullying seemed
mostly fine too did they not care that
their nephews were bastards yeah I mean
like aegon is very lacks like aegon
doesn't really seem to care about
anything he's not very enthusiastic
about the prospect of marrying his
sister Helena he just sort of wants to
drink and flirt with serving girls and
you know I think you know like he's kind
of a dick
um but he's not like super harmful but
he's being pushed into violence anyway
you know what I mean like it might be
better if aegon was allowed to just
drink and just be dumb rather than
pushing him into you know a potential
conflict like it's the tragedy of all of
these kids being forced into conflict
thanks for Super Chat from tamberley we
will talk about the next episode preview
later
thanks for the Super Chat from Atri yeah
so we discussed before that Helena says
this thing about like the loom uh weaves
spools of black thread and black thread
and green thread together dragons of
Flesh and Dragons of thread and I think
that that's talking about Bloodlines
family trees weddings marriages all like
interconnecting people into a fabric of
the royal family like a tapestry
it's like a metaphor for the
interconnectedness of the family dragons
of flesh meaning the targaryens and
their family and their intermarriages
green being Hightower and red being
Targaryen
thanks for the Super Chat from Stuart
who says they are going fast they are
going to do five season we might get to
the blackfyre stuff
uh well they're telling the story of
this time period and this conflict uh
with Rainier and Alison and
they have talked about potentially
covering all the time periods after this
current story
um if this current story goes well like
they talked about House of the Dragon
could become like an anthology kind of
like the crown where they tell different
stories in different time periods but
the plan currently as I understand it is
just to cover this particular conflict
and this particular time period right
now
we talked about Lenor and sea smoke
um maybe someone else will claim C smoke
maybe not because Lenor is still alive
we answered that one
um thanks for the Super Chat from mineth
hashtag Laris and from boybrushed and
from JD who says I are we going to
ignore the fact that Daemon and Rainier
murdered a man to get married
yeah so I I think what happened is that
raniera and Daemon
deliberately let Lena and Carl get away
um like we saw Daemon on drift Mark
killing that guy but as as you say JD
they did murder this guy
like they murdered this random servant
guy and burned him in a fireplace to be
like the decoy corpse so everyone thinks
Lenor is dead so yeah like I was saying
before that you know letting Lena and
Carl Go free makes it look like Rainier
and Daemon are good guys but they did
still murder this innocent man
so so we can't get to We Can't praise
demon and rhaenyra too much they did
murder this guy so so they are not the
only Allison is not the only person who
was villainous this episode Rainier and
Daemon did murder an innocent person
uh thanks for the Super Chat from R who
says the maester says Valyrian steel
Cuts clean when he's patching rhaenyra
up maybe that's why there's no blood on
the dagger uh when when rain when Alison
Cuts Rainier yeah maybe I I was pretty
worried for Rainier back then
um that that was like that was a cut in
renyra's wrist that Alison made with
that dagger
um if if that was me I would not be as
calm as Rainier was about that deep cut
in her arm I I I think there's some I
think there's some blood vessels in
there guys but uh she seems pretty
relaxed about it and then she goes on to
cut herself more for the wedding with
Daemon so there's a lot of blood flying
around this episode
in the book of course is named Fire and
Blood
uh thanks for the Super Chat from live
performances from jayshu who says rainy
rainy Targaryen looks like Kristen Bale
Christian Bale interesting take thanks
for the Super Chat from Ashley who says
that rhaenyra used Alison's rage on
purpose she's leaning into the rumors
now she saw a chance to gain the higher
moral ground and she took it yeah yeah
Rhino was absolutely like using Alison's
attack as a way of showing everyone that
like hey look Alison is a motorist
maniac and I'm the good guy that
definitely is what was going on there uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Jared who
says Reading A Feast for Crows for the
first time and wow are there some hot D
spoilers in there yeah I mean like when
George wrote The Game of Thrones books
and when the original Game of Thrones
show was made they didn't know that
there was going to be a TV show about
this time period and this conflict so in
the books and in uh the original Game of
Thrones show uh there is some stuff
about like what happens at the end of
this conflict
um you know you can look at it on
YouTube there's a scene where Joffrey
says some things about what happens in
this conflict so yeah so yeah you can
search that out if you want but um yeah
there are there are there are spoilers
out there but we're not going to discuss
spoilers here
thanks for the Super Chat from tambi Lee
who says the person who Alison should be
upset with is her dad he tossed her into
the Dragon's Den
yeah I like Alison has just sort of gone
along with Otto for the longest time
like she has obeyed him like it was Otto
who pushed Alison to marry King viserys
in the first place and it was Otto who
told Alison that there will be conflict
with rhaenyra and rhaenyra's children
um and I feel like Alison should start
to push back against her father like
especially after this 10-year Gap like
Otto has been away for such a long time
and Alison has started to assert her own
power you know when she walked in with a
green dress and she called Rainier a
stepdaughter and she was really sort of
being more confident in her own power
and also you know like Alison is
increasingly overriding viserys and
asserting her power so
it's interesting that but you know as
soon as her dad comes home she just
turns into a little girl again you know
like she just instantly regresses to
being under his influence and so I
wonder if that will continue or if
there'll be a moment when Alison is like
hey wait a minute I'm in some deep [ __ ]
partly because I was listening to Otto
when I shouldn't have been like I'm I'm
not a kid anymore I should I don't have
to do what my dad says I'm the queen of
the Seven Kingdoms so I wonder like how
their relationship will develop
um I mean I think that as this conflict
gets worse and worse I think there's
going to be moments when the characters
have moments of clarity and go like oh
no like I I have I have made a series of
poor decisions
thanks for the Super Chat from mineth
who says uh so your kid had their eye
cut out oh yeah it happened happens all
the time I mean eyes are just popping
out every which way at all my family
gatherings thanks for the Super Chat
from navini who says would you like to
see vegan Targaryen in the show vagon
the dragonless arch maester vagon so
yeah like the vagon was one of the
children of uh Joe Harris and alisane
who was uh considered briefly to maybe
potentially be the king of Westeros but
they decided not to because he's a nerd
and no one likes him and he doesn't like
anyone in return
um I I don't think vagon needed to be in
this show
um I mean he could have been like an
extra at the Council of Harren Hall
flashback but you know this show wasn't
really about that era I mean it could
have been
um
I I believe that George Martin in an
interview was
or Ryan Condell said that you know
George was pushing for this show to
start earlier back in time
um like they really could have spent a
bit more time with Joe Harris's Reign
and Joe Harris's children uh because you
know there was this whole previous
succession dispute where some people
were saying that rhaenys should take the
throne or rainis son Lenor should be
there to the throne
um and the show just sort of gave us the
cliff notes of that in this little
flashback sequence at the start of
episode one but they certainly could
have spent more time there um so if it
is that house of the Dragon ends up
um covering other time periods yeah
maybe they could cover the reign of
joharis and alisane that could be
interesting
um where are all those other targaryens
stretch says in the live chat yeah that
I mean is uh I I suppose bloody Sarah is
dead now but like yeah Harrison Alison
had a whole bunch of kids like we know
about uh Amon father of rhaenys and
Balon father of viserys and Daemon and
Alyssa but like that there was like a
dozen of them and that's why in the
opening sequence there's this explosion
of Bloodlines
um here these are the children of
joharis and alisane and most of them met
tragic ends one way or another
most of Jairus and alisane's children
died young one way or another
um
but I guess vemond
Raymond lived these days in the Citadel
and I suppose died of old age unless
there are any little uh Targaryen
maester bastards running around
somewhere uh thanks for the Super Chat
from biotic who says rhaenyra should
have been like if this I'll take two
husbands she has no respect for the
rules anyway yeah yeah I mean rhaenyra
was telling Daemon that like yeah I
can't marry you until lane or is dead
because I can't marry multiple husbands
um but you know I mean polygamy has been
a thing like Daemon was saying
previously that you know aegon took
multiple wives maegor took multiple
wives why can't I take multiple wives
aegon and maegor were like not that long
ago
um historically speaking this was aegon
here and maegor here
um
it wasn't that long ago that targaryens
did have multiple
spouses so maybe Daemon and Rainier
could do the same but I think that you
know it's important to have legitimacy
like they're not just marrying out of
romance and love they're marrying out of
a political Alliance and for that
political Alliance to be respected it
helps if they actually follow the rules
of the Kingdom that they're in so um I
think that's why they were not doing
polygamy thanks for the Super Chat from
ginsai who says how is Kristen still on
the Kings guard he not only kills
Joffrey elonmouth at a feast but he
obeys the consort over the ruling
Monarch and tries to harm the air
uh he didn't obey Alison's order to cut
an eye out of lucerus if that's what you
mean
um I think Daemon sort of stopped
Kristen like Alison says sir Kristen
bring me the eye of luceris and Kristen
was like uh maybe no you will do no such
thing you're sworn to me vasera says
like Kristen Kristen does not attack
yeah he says as you're protector so
Kristen refuses to attack Luke
um I think it is questionable how
everyone is Chill about the death of
John Joffrey lawnmuth but um he didn't
obey Alison
yeah thanks for the Super Chat from
tambi Lee who says no disrespect to Emma
Darcy but I enjoy Millie Alcock more as
Rainier or Millie Alcock was the young
raniera I think merely displays anger
more in her face and I would like to see
more anger being expressed by Emma
Yeah well yeah I agree that Millie was
more expressive as Rainier which makes
sense because like she's an angry
teenager whereas Emma Darcy is playing a
politician who has I think had to learn
to be a little bit more restrained
um as a result of you know being a
politician for so long and having all
these secrets that she's had to keep so
I think in a lot of ways it makes sense
that rhaenyra is now a bit more
constrained a bit more serious she's not
a teenager anymore
but I agree that you know Amelia
alcock's performance as young rain era
was very charismatic and fun
um so I hope that we'll see a little bit
more of that I mean maybe in her new
marriage to Daemon rhaenyra might show a
little bit more of her like old fun
rebellious fiery side I mean she said as
much when she was like hey we
targaryen's a fiery let's bring that
fire together let's be fiery together so
maybe we'll see a little bit more
personality from marinero there but I
think at the moment like Rainier is
under so much pressure because she's
terrified that her bastard children will
be revealed as bastards she's terrified
that she might be disinherited that like
like just as much as Alison is afraid
that her children might be put to the
sword Rainier is gonna be afraid that
her children could be killed because her
her children are a threat to Alison's
children and their claims so you know I
think Emma's got a lot to be worried
about Rainier has a lot to be worried
about so I think it makes a lot of sense
that she's more restrained
thanks for the Super Chat from John who
says who is your favorite Targaryen in
this show
there's a lot of targaryens to choose
from I think that Daemon is fun and I
think Matt Smith's performance is fun
and he's got a lot of layers and a lot
of fun stuff going on with him I find
aegon amusing like aegon's performance
as the sort of like
Teenage drunkard who's just annoyed at
everything and he's a total dick bag
um Ian I think an amusing way Helena is
so mysterious Baylor and Reina like we
haven't seen much of Baylor and Reina
yet I mean it was fun to see them
bumbling amond uh and I hope we get to
see you know Baylor's Dragon soon so
yeah I I guess Daemon is one of the most
fun for me but uh I mean none of the
targaryens are boring I mean one of the
senses that we do get is that you know
like someone like Lena especially is is
fairly like level-headed like the
valerians are more level-headed whereas
it's the targaryens who are fiery I
guess rhaenys is also quite level-headed
like I think it's an interesting Dynamic
that they've gone with for Corliss and
rainy so like Corliss is the one who's
agitating for we need to claim our
Birthright we need power like I'm
willing to fight War for my son Lane ore
and his children
or as rainy as the Targaryen is chill
and she's the one who's saying I'm over
it and I wonder if maybe that will
change like maybe rhaenys's personality
will change a bit because like you know
she was saying everything's cool like
let's not fight but now that both of her
children have died in one year she might
be angry she might be traumatized she
might she might change her mind about
how relaxed she was previously so I
would be interested if um rhaenys
changes
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Yogi
who says in essos Leno and Carl get to
have sex all day thanks for the Super
Chat from JD who says do we really think
Daemon would allow aegon and Alison to
live in peace after Rainier ascends the
throne even if they don't press their
claim I mean in episode one we saw
Daemon on the iron throne
and you know partly he was being
provocative but I think partly he was
showing his interest in power and you
know like viserys in episode one says
that Daemon doesn't really want to be
king he doesn't really want power power
is too much responsibility Daemon just
wants to be free and do what he wants
but like Daemon also has this deep thing
where he's angry and feels rejected by
viserys that he was not made Heir and he
was not made hand and so claiming power
is this deep emotional thing for Daemon
um and now that he's married Rainier and
he has this Bond terrain era like yeah
like maybe he will want to help rhaenyra
take the throne
um and rhaenyra does seem to be deeply
invested in in defending her claim and I
think that at this point like it it no
longer is even about the throne
it's the principle of it uh like they
don't like rhaenyra's side and Allison's
side they don't want to submit to each
other like even like I I mean would
rhaenyra enjoy being the ruler of the
Seven Kingdoms on the throne would
Alison enjoy being the mother of King
aegon Targaryen maybe not like I don't
think their lives would be better from
being King like I think they all know
that having power is just a source of
you know responsibility and Mortal
danger and long boring Council meetings
like rhaenyra was not enjoying the
council meeting last episode like she
was fiddling with uh with a council ball
in the small council meeting last
episode
um and you know Alison was was fairly
grumpy as well no no one has fun being a
politician but I think that they are not
willing to back down anymore because
it's it's personal blood has been
spilled their children
um have been bloodied in this conflict
and so if they back down now it's like
they are betraying their damaged
children they are betraying the the
people who died to get them here lane or
and Lane well not Lino but lainer and
like the bloodied kids so I think we're
entering a uh spiral of violence thanks
zaveko and thanks sword Blitz who says
they made it a point
that Kristen was on watch tonight and
the King asked who was on watch wonder
where he was when the fight happened
yeah that's an interesting point because
yeah like when viserys was leaving the
funeral
um and when he called he called Alison
to Emma
um yeah you have the Night's Watch sir
Kristen so Kristen was on watch when
vegar got stolen and amond had his eyes
slashed out so yeah Kristen did not do a
great job and like it's funny because
Baylor and Rayna that night they woke up
they heard what was going on and they
alerted Jace so like they acted they
noticed they confronted the issue but
Kristen didn't do [ __ ] so yeah I think
that's a great Point Kristen's job as
Night Watch was um not not very
competent not doing very well
uh Philippe says I love the scene where
everyone is disobeying viserys
um yeah viserys was going silence
silence listen to me and most people
were not really listening to him and not
accepting his Justice and nodding not
accepting his um Authority
thanks for the Super Chat from Zachary
who says the Swifty Squad is eager for
more a [ __ ] abridged
there is a podcast called Game of
Thrones Abridged by a rap scally and by
the name of alt Swift X I've never seen
the appeal personally of alt Swift X
just seems like a uh poor imitation of
alt shift X but some people do enjoy
that show and I would not be shocked if
there was more episodes of Game of
Thrones Abridged in the near future so
you can check out Arc shrift X all
shrift X is almost on 100 000
subscribers on the alt shifter X YouTube
channel and I shudder to think uh what
what new content might come from that
particular den of depravity and iniquity
if uh Old Trip decks hit 100K
subscribers so uh watch out for rock
shift X thanks for the Super Chat from
cosmic who says am I the only person who
has no idea who was thrown into the fire
in place of lanor I think it was this
serving man who Daemon killed this fella
here I assume that is who ended up in
the fireplace so uh rhaenya and Daemon
did a good thing letting Leno and Carl
Run free together but they did a bad
thing that they murdered this guy and
turned him into a human s'more thanks
for the Super Chat from Josh who says is
this the prettiest or artsy fartiest
episode in the Game of Thrones
television Canon thus far visually
speaking I mean some of it was very dark
visually there was a lot of blurry dark
stuff in this episode
um yeah I guess there were some
interesting cinematography there were
some interesting shots there was light
was being played with in some
interesting ways I I don't I don't think
there are many shots like this in the
original Game of Thrones TV show
um there's a lot of fire light as well
which is always representing like anger
and rage and emotion every second scene
in this show is lit by fire in the
background especially the Targaryen
characters whenever they're talking
about their feelings that's fire in the
background to show their internal
emotional burning fire so um
so yeah I I do like how it's shot there
are some very pretty shots this is a
very pretty shot
so yeah I think they're doing a little
bit more
cinematographically than the Game of
Thrones show ever did like yeah this
shot is very lovely as well so yeah I
agree with you though
um
josu says imagine not having a high-end
HDR OLED TV yeah that's the thing like
I'm sure this show looks great if you
have a three thousand dollar TV that's
big and also if you have like a gigabit
internet connection that can stream this
video at full quality like that's the
thing like like they can make this show
as pretty as they want but if most
people are watching this show on an
unreliable 1080p video stream on a TV or
God forbid on a laptop that does not
have the capability to show all the
Glorious colors and the HDR and
everything it's kind of pointless isn't
it if they allowed us to actually
download these video files in high
quality we wouldn't have that problem
that's the problem with video streaming
video streaming is like it's it's
convenient and it's immediate but
there's a I'm not I'm not the first to
to say that there's a lot of problems
with the current video streaming
landscape and it doesn't work very well
for everyone
um whenever someone like makes an album
after they mix it in the studio and they
balance the audio and they get it all
perfect they then like put it on a CD
and listen to it in their car on their
crappy car speakers and they do that so
that they can hear the way most people
hear it most people don't hear content
the way it is created in their fancy
Studio they hear it on like a iPod
Shuffle or on a Spotify stream so like
in the same way people who make
multi-million dollar TV shows they
should make sure that it looks good on a
small screen with a crappy internet
connection because that's how a lot of
people are watching this stuff uh
despite David Lynch's complaints that is
the reality uh thanks for the Super Chat
from protapier who says my head Canon is
that when Alison cut rhaenyra the
Valyrian steel dagger became
lightbringer
all right let's do some prophecy talk uh
because in the books there is all sorts
of stuff about the the prophecy the the
white walkers will be defeated in azori
and the prince that was promised and
there's it's a whole thing and part of
the prophecy is this thing called
lightbringer and lightbringer is a sword
that will be used to defeat the white
walkers apparently but there's a lot of
speculation about like is lightbringer a
literal sword is lightbringer the sword
Dawn the mysterious meteor forged sword
of house Dane or his light ring or a
metaphor for Dragons there's a lot of
different
um ideas about what lightbringer is and
like in the TV show this Valyrian steel
Cuts board blade was used by Aya to kill
the night king So This Cat's ball of
Valyrian steel dagger did play the role
of lightbringer in the sense that it was
the blade that saved the world
um and in the books part of the story of
lightbringer or a story of lightbringer
is that it is forged with the lifeblood
of a loving wife Azor ahai killed his
wife nissenissa and that's what made
lightbringer lightbringer
so the blade needs blood to be
lightbringer
um and you know we do see the blade kill
some people
um I mean the blade got uh Catelyn
Stark's blood in Game of Thrones episode
two uh when that when that cat Spore
assassin went after bran
um so it was bloodied with catelyn's
blood and then the blade was used to
kill Littlefinger uh in Game of Thrones
episode Game of Thrones season seven
um
and then it killed the night King so
yeah I mean maybe in some sense Allison
slashing Rainier with that blade was a
was another Blood Sacrifice that
empowered this blade to eventually kill
the night king
um
I mean really you know I I don't think
that was really quite a sacrifice you
know Alison was trying to slash at her
enemy oh well no well she accidentally
cut rhaenyra so I don't think that that
particular moment quite had the
narrative wait to be the sacrifice that
makes the blade lightbringer but you
know I think this is a good and fun and
interesting line of questioning like
like are they going to do things with
that blade that make it sort of fit the
prophecy because one of the
disappointments of Game of Thrones
season 8 for a lot of people was that
the prophecy stuff didn't really make a
lot of sense with regards to the book
law because Arya Stark is not a
Targaryen and the prophecy says that a
Targaryen or at least the targaryens
think that the prophecy says that a
Targaryen will save the world so you
know there's lots of ambiguity and since
the show is paying more attention like
like this show House of the Dragon is
emphasizing the prophecy in ways that
the original Game of Thrones show never
did I think it's worth keeping an eye on
um
what that's gonna be
um
yeah and what and yeah while we are
complaining I can see some people
agreeing in the live chat that um
Digital streaming sucks for a lot of
people the uh the subtitles is something
else that I have seen people complain
about because the Valyrian subtitles
that are hard-coded like burned on
um to the house of the Dragon stream on
HBO it's tiny tiny tiny little yellow
text and I'm sure when the people in
Hollywood are making this show and
they're making this show on monitors
that are as large as
um my car and they are watching on they
are watching it in 4k and they've got
the fancy computers and internet
connections I'm sure those tiny yellow
subtitles are very easy to read for them
but a lot of people are watching these
on small screens and they can't read
this text very easily especially if the
internet is not great and it drops to
720p so yeah we can we can [ __ ] all day
about that stuff anyway anyway yeah
yellow font why yellow anyway thanks for
the Super Chat from Evan who says I feel
like viserys
ought to Exile Allison and dismiss Otto
again seems wise honestly it might be
good for the kingdom if if vasera said
you know what enough with the high
Towers I've had enough of the high
Towers they're leaving and I'll just
raise aegon and amond and Helena myself
like maybe that would be better for the
kingdom but I don't think viserys is
eager to Exile his wife now that tends
not to go down well
um might not be great for their
relationship if he exiled his wife
thanks for the Super Chat from Kevin who
says Daemon wearing a hoodie equals
trouble well I think this episode is the
first time that Daemon wearing a hoodie
was doing a good deed like he was he was
letting Carl Go free with lanor hood but
he did also murder that guy so well he's
not wearing a hood when he does the
murder so that disproves the theory that
Daemon is always uh wearing a hoodie
when he's being evil there was um it was
funny with uh Raya Royce
um when Daemon was wearing this
comically large Hood like how enormous
is that hood it looks like it was made
for Gregor Clegane that look look at
that thing that's ridiculous daemon's
head isn't that large why is that hood
so enormous I heard some speculation by
Joanna Robinson uh on a ringer podcast
saying that maybe the reason why Daemon
has such a comically enormous hood is
that they needed a stunned person to do
this stunt with this horse like they
didn't want to put Matt Smith's pretty
face in the way of a horse hoof so
that's a stunt person and in order to
hide the fact that it's a stunned person
Daemon is wearing a gigantic Hood to
cover his face from the back
that sounds like a good theory to me and
I heard that from Joanna Robinson on the
ringer verse podcast which is also a
good show that you should check out
thanks for the Super Chat from sitali
who says do you buy that lane or would
agree to abandon his family right after
he's tell he's told rhaenyra that he's
super committed to her
um yeah yeah it yeah because Lena told
Rainier like hey like I'm ready to take
my responsibilities seriously I'm ready
to be a real father to Jason Luke and
Joff I'm ready to try to have sex with
you even though I'm not sexually
attracted to you
um but then next minute Lena and Carl
just abandoned their families their
homes their dragons their Birthright
their castle and just went off to hang
out in essos which yeah that's a bit of
a turn but I think that you know it's
very clear that Leonor didn't want to do
any of those things like Lena didn't
want to play husband to Lenor he saw it
as a responsibility and and I guess that
I mean maybe there should have been a
scene or maybe it was sort of implied
that there would have been a
conversation
um maybe there should have been a
conversation where Rainier is like okay
I get it like I I re I release you from
that responsibility like I appreciate
that you're trying to do the right thing
but you know what I think it's better
for everyone if you just live the life
that you actually want to live free with
Carl rather than living a life with me
but yeah I agree that it's still crazy
that he abandons everything because like
you know we saw I I mean you know Elena
always wanted to get away like last
episode Lena was saying like I want to
go to the step Stones I want to have
Adventure I want to get sapphires big as
chestnuts so like it is consistent like
he did want to get away
um
and it doesn't sound like he had the
best relationship with his father call
us given that his father called us was
like hoping the whole time that lanewell
would turn straight
um but you know but but I guess one of
the interesting things as we have been
saying is what about lanor's Dragon sea
smoke because like in the books it says
that sea smoke is lenor's pride and joy
like he loves his Dragon sea smoke and
we saw him in episode three riding sea
Smoke on the stepstones and having an
enormously fun time hashtag that's what
I call pod racing he was he was loving
it flying that Dragon sea smoke
um and and the bond with the dragon is
like is like a sacred thing so would
lane or want to abandon his Dragon like
that maybe his Dragon will follow him
maybe his Dragon will fly East to him
that would be cool
uh thanks for the Super Chat from L from
Jess who says viserys's daughter
oriented favoritism is showing you
reckon that Visa is sided with Ray Nero
more than he sided with Alison I feel
like Alison was I mean yeah I mean
visera said like what do you want me to
do like do you want me to cut out the
eye of my grandchild Luke like do you
think that will make things better
I I mean maybe what viserys should have
done was said something like okay like
you know amond and Luke and Jace and
maybe Baylor and Rhino they did this
fight they caused this violence so they
all shall be punished like they all will
be in detention no dragon lessons for
them for the next month and no cookies
and no Fortnight and maybe you should
have like exiled some of those kids or
like sent them away or like done
something to punish them
in order to do something resembling
Justice because I think you know that's
the reason why Alison attacked Luke and
attacked rhaenyra is because she was not
getting any justice from viserys there
was no consequences so there was no
satisfaction so I think this errors
should have given some kind of
consequences to try to settle things
without mutilating any children because
that's what Justice is when we attempt
to make Justice we attempt to make
everybody happy and we we hope to give
consequences to crimes hopefully without
any children losing any body parts that
always is the Hope
that always is the Hope uh thanks for
the Super Chat from mine who says I
think you missed my chat because I had
to use the restroom uh yeah no we
already talked about that one
um yeah Amon Targaryen is not bloodraven
they are both missing an eye and they
are both very cool characters but yeah
we talked about that
bloodraven comes much later
thanks to the Super Chat from Icy Fire
and from Peter Flynn who says are all 17
to 18 dragons descended from the three
that conquered Westeros could inbreeding
cause their downfall faster than humans
yeah that's a fun idea maybe maybe those
dragons have a Habsburg chin from their
generations of inbreeding because yeah
like I mean we are told that the
targaryens left Valeria uh with their
dragons and with their slaves the
targaryens had slaves that they brought
with them to Dragonstone
um and yeah they brought their dragons
with them I don't know how many dragons
the targaryens brought with them to
Dragonstone
um I mean valerion was one of the
original dragons that they took with
them
um I I don't remember how many they had
on Dragonstone but yeah they bred and
reproduced on Dragonstone and at the
time of aegon the Conqueror they only
had balerion maraxis and Vega I mean
look we don't know how dragon breeding
works there does appear to be some
differences between vegar and uh sorry
between all the different dragons now
like caraxis looks very different to the
others but maybe that's not genetic
diversity maybe karaxi's has a noodle
neck because he is the product of 300
years of dragon incest
five yeah thank you in the live chat
yeah the books do say a number it's five
dragons that the targaryens had on
Dragonstone originally so yeah I mean is
that enough genetic diversity
Maybe
um maybe they're messed up thanks for
the Super Chat from JW who says it feels
like the writers haven't fully
considered the implications of a
Wandering Dragon Rider reeks of fan
fiction
um I agree that it's important like the
bond between sea smoke and C Smoke's
Rider lanor like what what's the deal
there like can you abandon a dragon like
that I don't think there are any
examples
um in the books of a writer like
abandoning and permanently separating
from their dragon I mean Daenerys chains
up
um I mean Daenerys is estranged from her
Dragon drogon for a while like Dragon
drogon just like goes loose in the
Dothraki sea and goes loose around the
slaves Bay area for a while when
Daenerys sort of rejects drogon but then
drogon comes back so and they
re-establish that connection so I don't
know if you ever can like permanently
reject Your Dragon
um
so we'll see smoke follow lane or maybe
see smoke will believe that Lenor is
dead
I mean how would sea smoke know that
Lenor is still alive like maybe there's
some psychic connection that can cross
over a continent but if Lenor goes far
enough away like if Leno crosses the
narrow sea maybe you know with enough
distance it's impossible for
sea smoke to know
I mean you know that there is sometimes
a sense in the books that the dragons
know things like you know balerion the
black dread
flew back to valyria seemingly in the
books earlier in the reign of King
joheras and he carried this Targaryen
girl a Rhea Targaryen on his back and
urea's body got infested with terrifying
Valyrian
worms fire worms with human faces
infested area's body and she died that's
a whole thing in the book
um
so yeah I uh I wonder I wonder what will
happen with sea smoke thanks for the
Super Chat from Gunner who says kind of
sad what happens to Helena if we get
another time skip when she gets her
children
no spoilers here thanks for the Super
Chat from Pro who says aegon reminds me
of Bobby B yeah all aegon seems to want
to do is drink and have sex
um and unlike Bobby B aegon does not
have the redeeming characteristic of
like having been a cool Warrior
previously or having overthrown a Mad
King aegon does not really have any
redeeming characteristics I think he is
amusing like he's funny to watch
um I like how he calls amond de [ __ ] in
the previous episode but like he's funny
but uh yeah he doesn't share any of the
redeeming qualities of Robert knows that
they have thanks for the Super Chat from
uh the African sci-fi scholar who says
I'll take a night King's javelin throw
through an old dragon scale any day yeah
so I mean with regards to the
vulnerability of dragons in Game of
Thrones season seven uh we saw the night
King do a do a Olympic javelin throw
perform elements and killed daenerys's
dragon
viserion with his icy Javelin
um and that's not a euphemism but unless
the night king turns up in House of the
Dragon I'm not expecting javelins to be
a major plot point in House of the
Dragon
thanks for the Super Chat from Neil who
says for a goat with a candle on his
head hugs from Berlin thank you Neil
thanks for the Super Chat from Freddy
who says does Daemon have affection for
his daughters he hasn't spoken to them
since their mother died at least not in
a scene or are they just for him a
byproduct of his relationship with Lena
yeah I mean Reina Targaryen was
complaining last episode that
um Daemon ignores her Reina said and
just focuses on Baylor so you know and
we saw Daemon teaching Baylor the
Valyrian language
um so he does seem to have some interest
in Baylor but he seems to have an
interest in Baylor because she's a
dragon rider so does Daemon only love
his daughter because she has a dragon
and a dragon is power
um there was a
there was an image that was shared by
HBO of Daemon hugging and consoling
Baylor and Rayna after the death of Lena
but that wasn't used in the actual
episode and in the actual episode we had
Daemon just sort of like awkwardly
standing next to his grieving children
and then he walked away
it's like what are you doing Daemon just
like walking away from your grieving
children after the death of their mother
um and yeah there was like this image as
well that was released but we didn't
actually get any dialogue so it looks as
though maybe they filmed a scene where
Daemon was consoling his daughters but
it didn't actually make it into any
episodes so
yeah like I don't it doesn't seem like
Daemon is a great dad at least you know
what's in the uh episodes itself I hope
we get to see more interactions with
them and we learn what their deal is it
would not Shock me if Daemon was a [ __ ]
dad like he's not a great person all in
all
um
so yeah I wonder how those kids will do
it'd be tough being daemon's daughter
thanks for I mean but I think the dragon
riding thing is important like like they
they clearly distinguish the demon loves
Baylor or shows more interesting Baylor
than Reina because Baylor has a dragon
so I think you know there aren't a lot
of conversations happening in the show
about who has dragons and the importance
of having dragons but I think Daemon is
definitely aware and definitely paying
attention
thanks celadic we just talked about like
yeah I think Daemon
he's interested in Baylor for her Dragon
but we haven't seen a whole lot of like
genuine affection
from Daemon for his children as of yet
uh thanks for the Super Chat from Keen
aesthetic who says the targaryens
started with five dragons on Dragonstone
and then had only three dragons during
aegon's Conquest uh and then 130 years
after the conquest we are 120 years
after the conquest uh is now and now
there's dragons all over so Keane is
saying where did all these dragons come
from why are there lots of dragons now
when there weren't many dragons
previously and that is a good question
and I think that it borderline is a plot
hole
um but I think the best explanation we
have is that there is a sense of like
rising and falling tides of magic in
this world
um like quaith in book two says that oh
Daenerys like you birthed dragons and
now there is more magic coming into the
world
um so so there is like this intimate
connection between dragons in the world
and all magic just the background
radiation level of magic that's in this
universe
um and so maybe you know and there's
also this thing about the white walkers
where it's like uh do the white walkers
come when the winter is cold or is the
winter cold because the white walkers
came and so even with the white what and
the question of like why did the white
walkers come when they did why why now
after thousands of years of absence of
the white walkers back now and I think
that the answers to all these questions
might be
magic naturally just comes and goes like
the tides it's like el Nina and El Nino
um there's just this sort of natural
weird cycle and you can see that as like
an unbalanced thing connected to the
seasons because in this world the
seasons are irregular sometimes winter
goes for 10 years sometimes summer goes
for 10 years sometimes it's only two
years you get short Winters and long
Winters and it's all out of kilter and
there was a blurb on one of the Game of
Thrones books the blurb of the book said
that after a what was it after a pretor
natural event the seasons are disordered
or something and George Martin has said
that the seasons will be restored to
order the seasons will be resolved at
the end of the series so my point is
that maybe we're currently in this like
weird situation where magic and the
seasons and the winters in the summer
and the white walkers and the dragons
all this Fire and Ice is just sort of
careening around and changing swinging
like a pendulum it's all in this
unnatural
unbalanced swinging changing flux
and maybe that's why sometimes dragon
eggs do hatch and there are lots of
dragons everywhere and sometimes they
don't and sometimes there are white
walkers everywhere and sometimes they're
around because it's this
cyclical wonky thing and maybe they will
restore balance to the force at the end
of the series and then maybe the seasons
will become regular and then maybe there
will be no more dragons and no more
white walkers I think that that would
work as like an ending and as a
resolution to the
changing tides of magic and dragons in
the show and in the books
um is that Sunfire yeah that's that's a
good question so like we have it has
been mentioned that uh aegon Targaryen
has a beautiful golden dragon called
Sunfire and maybe maybe that's it
could it be Cyrax instead Cyrax is
yellow it is a little confusing
um it's a little difficult to tell the
dragons apart because yeah we have the
golden Sunfire and we have the yellow
Cyrax and arax is also said to be I
think like pale with golden highlights
uh Luke's Dragon arax
um I like how you know karaxi's looks
very different to the others and vegar
is huge so it looks very different sea
smoke looks quite distinctive but I hope
that Sunfire I don't know I I kind of
hope that that's not Sunfire because
Sunfire is meant to look magnificent
like Sunfire is the most often described
as like wow this is a really [ __ ]
cool looking Dragon you got there it's
like a any Pokemon it really stands out
so I hope that when Sunfire turns up we
notice like it is so like glittering
gold that it's like impossible not to
notice how cool it is that's what I hope
that's what I hope
uh Patrick in the live chat says that
the flying one is Cyrax yeah yeah that
he's got that sort of flat head doesn't
he Cyrax or her
so yeah maybe it's not maybe it's not
Sunfire
um thanks for the Super Chat from what
in the Tambor who says I like how they
thematically connected vegar to the sea
with all the rigging and the ropes which
makes sense because Lena was a valerion
and the valerians are connected to the
Sea yeah that's a great point I didn't
notice that because yeah there are all
these ropes on Vega's back that were
like swinging around when Lena was
flying and yeah that totally does evoke
the rigging on a ship and the valerians
have this deep connection with the sea
as as we saw when they like dropped the
coffin in the sea so yeah I I think
that's a good point thanks for the Super
Chat from Brinks who says I don't quite
understand amon's hostility towards Lena
and the Valerian kids had he even met
them before uh yeah yeah I mean we saw
um a bit of hostility between the kids
in the yard uh in the previous episode
we saw that you know when they were
sparring and training
um there was a little bit of hostility I
mean it was mostly like aegon was being
hostile to people but I think Amon you
know he was part of that sort of
Alison's Kids versus Rainier as kids
Vibe
um but yeah like it is a bit extreme the
way amond you know started fighting
these kids I mean I think they started
it didn't they who who threw the first
punch like aemon said something mean and
then the girls Baylor and Reina first
attacked aemon so they started the
actual fight well all right all right
you know she ran towards him and aemond
pushed her down so
she like ran towards him and then and
then Amon started throwing punches and
then the boys got in on it as well
um but yeah like I think the reason why
amond was so sort of hostile is that he
was on this mad rush of power
he had just taken control of the most
powerful weapon of war in this world
um so I think he's full of adrenaline
he's like full of like you know he's
just like shaking with energy uh and he
channeled that into aggression because
he's got this you know he was bullied
and he feels like he's got a chip on his
shoulder so that kind of makes sense
um
yeah yeah aemond started the hostility
with words
but he didn't start like the physical
violence did he we can take a closer
look later but I I think that the you
know and was definitely being a dick I
mean you know I'll feed you to my dragon
and I think picking up a rock like he
escalated it with like weapons was it
aemond who first picked up a rock
yeah we we can we can we can
examine that later but um yeah I think
that that's what was going on with amond
emotionally
thanks for the Super Chat from Isaiah
who says oh well yeah and as they say in
the live chat
um yeah and also part of why amond is
hostile to Jason Luke is because Luke
was one of the main people who gave
amond the pink dread pig in the previous
episode so aemond was bullied by Luke
specifically so that that's part of
where that hostility is coming from
and yeah in the books it's a little bit
different like in the books uh Bayla and
Rayna aren't involved in this fight uh
it's actually uh Joff Luke and also Yeah
well yeah it's Jace and Luke and also
Joff like the youngest child who's
currently like a baby is three years old
um at this point in the books and
it's actually Joff like the little
three-year-old who is the one who first
confronts aemond here they are Jace Luke
and Joff
um as they appear in the books
um and
I think uh yeah aemond pushed Joff into
a pile of dragon droppings
when Jeff tried to stop amond uh we
didn't get to see the dragon poop at
this episode sadly but otherwise the the
fight is quite similar
thanks for the Super Chat from Isaiah
who says what are your thoughts on
viserys's stroke game no comment uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Laura who
says what is laris's end game yeah well
there are some great lines in the book
talking about how Laris is an enigma and
historians to this day uh question what
were Larissa's motivations I think that
Laris is clearly
trying to get power
and he is making this conflict worse and
I think it's a bit like Littlefinger
creating chaos for his own empowerment
chaos is a ladder and I think he's also
got like a grudge against the world and
wants to punish the world for him being
looked down upon for being having a
funny leg and so on uh thanks for the
Super Chat from the caveless bear who
says do you think people were pretending
to not know about the heritage of
rhaenyra's children or they just didn't
care Corliss seems to rationalize it
yeah call us said pretty directly that
like you know he he he he doesn't
dispute that Jason Luke aren't his
biological grandchildren they aren't the
biological children of lane or but he
says he doesn't care like blood is not
that important to him he's more
interested in his name the valerion name
he wants uh jiserus valerion to win to
take the Throne of Westeros and he wants
luceris valerion to take driftmark and
height tired
so he knows and viserys knows and I
think everyone at court knows it's like
aegon says this episode like everyone
knows just look at them just look at
them and like you know viserys also
rationalized it saying that oh well
sometimes horses have funny looking
horses
um but um
yeah I think it's pretty obvious to
everyone because they have dark air and
because they have pale skin they don't
look like Lena so you know there are
political reasons and emotional reasons
why people choose not to see it but I
think everyone knows that they're
bastards and obviously that's a big deal
because bastards aren't meant to inherit
the same way true born children are so
arguably Alison's son aegon is heir to
the throw instead thanks for the Super
Chat from Jackie who says Laris is
telling Allison he owes her or else I
think I think he's behind blood and
cheese
um yeah so I I do think that you almost
get a sense that Laris is blackmailing
Alison like he's saying I can help you
but also I committed a murder in your
name and so I've Got dirt on you so I
could say that you know you ordered me
to kill Lord Owen strong and that would
be a big deal
um I I feel like you know Alison maybe
should just like turn larus in like
maybe Alison should say like hey King
viserys hey Otto Hightower Lara strong
murdered his father and brother and now
he's blackmailing me and it's really
[ __ ] up I think that Otto and viserys
would definitely side with Alison not
larus strong so you know I think the
fact that Alison is accepting Laris
along with all of his evil and all of
his dangers it shows that Alison is
willing to use Laris you know so I think
that uh I think that there is a degree
of culpability there that Allison is not
you know making Laris pay for his crime
thanks for well yeah and androgon in the
live chat says that Rainier could just
legitimize the strong boys once she
becomes Queen yeah that is another like
important issue that um probably should
be talked about uh because Kings and I
suppose Queens on the throne have the
power to legitimize it's like how Rus
Bolton made Ramsay Snow into the
legitimate Ramsay Bolton Ramsay was a
bastard who was legitimized and that
made it possible for him to actually
inherit the Dreadfort
um and so yeah theoretically rhaenyra or
King viserys uh could do the same thing
when they're on the throne they could
say hey uh Jason Luke and Joffrey yeah
they are bastards they are the children
of far and strong but I legitimize them
and once they're legitimized they no
longer have the taint of varsity
and then they could actually inherit
um and so in theory like legalistically
that would make them Rainier as
legitimate as but the fact is that you
know inheritance does not always work
the way that it's meant to in the law
books sometimes people have their own
opinions and sometimes there's disputes
regardless of what the laws might might
or might not actually say and like the
the exact you know rules of you know
primogenature and whatever are not all
that well established at this point
anyway like because you know maegor took
the throne that should have gone to
Annie's son and then like joharis took
the throne even though he had Elder
siblings and then like
um and then bloody uh rainey's was
passed over and so like it seems as
though it's always the eldest male but
then viserys changes his mind and says
no it goes to rhaenyra even though she's
female so like the rules have never been
clear or consistent so you know I think
something as simple as Jace Luke and
Joff being legitimized like it it it it
might hurt more than it helps I think
that maintaining the lie that these kids
our Lanos will probably do more
um for their support than legitimizing
them would because the thing is like if
you legitimize Jace Luke and Joff and
say that no they are not lane or
valerion's children You're Gonna Lose
the support of Lord Corliss valerion if
callus doesn't get to extend his legacy
if Corliss doesn't get to say those are
my grandchildren Carlos is not going to
support rhaenyra anymore and Corliss is
like the second most powerful Lord in
Westeros the valerians are the second
most powerful house with all of their
ships and with their dragons so it's a
really bad idea to antagonize the
valerions and if you admitted that Jason
Joff aren't valerians you would
antagonize the crap out of them
uh thanks for the Super Chat
from Interstellar green bean who says
the actors seem to be doing a great job
with the Valyrian language is the guy
who created the language on got involved
yeah yeah I think his name is David
Peterson invented the Valyrian language
George Martin in the books had like a
few words like drakaris and he also made
up some Dothraki words but then David
Peterson who was like the guy in
Hollywood for making fictional languages
actually turned to Dothraki into and
Valyrian into real languages and yeah I
I like how they use Valaria uh Valerian
in this show like it actually has a
political purpose you know because it is
the targaryens and the valerians who
speak it which emphasizes their Valyrian
ancestry and I like how Daemon and
rhaenyra use it as this
um intimate language between them to
like keep other people out of their
intimate conversations
uh so yeah I don't know if Peterson is
involved in this specifically but um he
did create the language and I do like
how they use it
thanks for the donation from Jo who says
I don't like Lenor leaving versus dying
it leaves sea Smoke's future in limbo uh
yeah like I would like them to address
it one way or the other what happens to
Sea smoke can anyone else claim C smoke
while Lenor is gone
um and we'll see smoke be sad I want to
know that too thanks for the Super Chat
from Laura and from chaos who says why
was Corliss so upset at that guy for
Lenor grieving in the sea well Lenor was
possibly a bit drunk and he was like
standing in the ocean during his
sister's funeral uh he was making a
scene he was making a bit of a scene
um and so callus told Carl to go and
fetch him
um and I quite like I quite liked the
line that Cole has used he said
something like uh retrieve your Patron
so next time you know someone's too
drunk and making a spectacle of
themselves at a party I think that their
significant other should be told
retrieve your Patron
um because Lena was sad his sister is
dead and I think that that is making him
confront his own mortality you know and
I think Lena is asking himself what is
my life like who am I like I'm married
to this person who I don't love and I've
got these children that I'm a father to
even though they're not really mine and
what I don't really want to be here but
I have these duties and and that's I
think is what leads him to make this you
know commitment to Rainier or sort of
offering to actually do his duty but
then rhaenyra I suppose allows him to
not take it I I almost wish there was a
moment where rhaenyra said hey Leno like
thanks but no thanks like you're allowed
to leave
that would make sense
um thanks for the Super Chat from the
cat files happy birthday Vega thanks for
the Super Chat from Max who says it's
worth noting that Alison tried making
amends multiple times when they were
teens and was pushed aside so I can
understand her adult motives did
Alison's try to make amends I mean
I don't know if she tried to make amends
exactly like like there was that I mean
there was that time when Rainier and
Alison like tried to
reconnect and then rhaenyra told Alison
that she
didn't have sex with Daemon or she said
you know Daemon never touched me like
there was that moment when they were
almost close again and so as a result of
that Alison then sided with rhaenyra and
said I believe her she didn't have sex
with anyone
um and even to Otto later she was saying
that I think that Rainier is innocent so
she was like supporting rhaenyra
um but then soon after Laris told Alison
about the moon t uh Alison started
getting suspicious and then she found
out from Kristen that it was a lie and
then that was when she went like full
against so you know yeah like like there
was a moment when they were more
friendly for a moment but it didn't last
that long
um
I think that she should have talked to
rhaenyra like I think the the first like
the first thing Rainier should have done
after hearing about the moon tea is said
like hey rhaenyra like I heard about
this Moon T be honest with me like stop
bullshitting me like I someone is
bullshitting me is it you like give
Rainier another chance to tell the truth
because like you know yes like she did
confront Alison earlier she did confront
rhaenyra earlier and rhaenyra probably
should have told the truth then
but like give Rainier another chance but
but Alison didn't give Rainier another
chance she just like came out in her
green dress and called her stepdaughter
and it was like fuse all around you know
so
I I think that it's understandable like
I mean Allison I think is not
communicating well like a father doesn't
communicate well
um
yeah I don't know I I wish that Allison
tried harder to make peace and I wish
that Rhino didn't lie so much both of
them have culpability in this conflict
uh thanks for the Super Chat from brainy
who says what was going on with the
conversation between aegon and amond
after the funeral yeah so aegon and
Helena are betrothed they are not
married yet but they are going to be
married is the plan they're engaged
aegon and Helena are our fiance and
fiancee is that the terminology
um even though their brother and sister
Targaryen incest to continue the dynasty
um thanks for the Super Chat from batter
who says Valyrian steel Cuts clean
Rainier against a flesh wound yeah look
I I feel like they made like not a big
deal of that giant wound in uh
rhaenyra's arm I feel like that should
have been more of a problem
thanks for the Super Chat from Sarang
who says did Laris walk into his mutes
Allah euron uh yeah that's a fun idea
yeah
um because there is this character year
on Greyjoy
who in the show is a idiot and in the
books is the most terrifying character
in the whole series uh euron in the
books is Magic and heretical and
murderous and incestuous and everything
evil
um and there is speculation that euron
might have skin changing powers and that
he may have been a former student of
bloodraven and that euron uh may be
walking into the Dusky woman the Dusky
woman is a woman who is Dusky believe it
or not
um and she is given to victarion as a
sex slave and some fans speculate that
euron might skin change into the Dusky
woman to keep an eye on Victorian even
though Victorian has sex with the Dusky
woman and if that sounds [ __ ] up it's
because it is and euron is
um and so
Sarang in the Super Chat is suggesting
that maybe Laris walks into his mutes
because the Dusky woman is also a mute
and also like euron's crew on his ship
the silence are all mutes they don't
have tongues and so I like the idea that
euron might walk into his crew as a way
of controlling them because I think it
would be difficult to control the crew
who can't talk you know a little bit
difficult to communicate so maybe Lara
Strong's silent mute men are controlled
by laryus through skin changing Magic
it's a wild Theory it's not it's not
likely to be true
um but I think it's a fun idea
okay
um it has been two and a half hours so
we're going to wrap this stream up soon
um I'm going to quickly respond to a
bunch of super chats I apologize uh for
any super chats that I miss but I'm
gonna do as many as I can and then we're
going to take a brief look at the on the
next episode preview and then we're
gonna wrap it up and we're gonna start
working on the explained video about
this episode
um so press the like button press the
Subscribe button
um and whatever you do don't go and
subscribe to the alt schwift X YouTube
channel because it would be a real
disaster if that channel hit 100K
subscribers uh thanks to Super Chat from
gingerbread who says rhaenyra helped
Lenor and Carl do exactly what Krispy
Kreme asked her to do great ending yeah
that's a really good point because
Kristen Cole asked rhaenyra to run away
with him to the east and maybe that's
what gave uh maybe that's what gave
Rainier the idea hey I should let Lena
do what Kristen wanted to do
um which I I guess that shows that
Rainier has been thinking about Kristen
and she has seen she has seen how badly
it went like making Kristen stick around
and I guess maybe that might have been
part of why Rainier decided to let Lena
go like forcing Kristen to stay around
uh went badly so maybe Rainier doesn't
want to force Leno to stay around she
allows him to go free and do what he
wants instead yeah I think that's a
that's a cool point
uh thanks for the Super Chat from tambi
Lee who says how is viserys throwing a
fit over Daemon and rhaenyra if his kids
are to be married quite the hypocrisy
well well no like viserys isn't like no
no one's angry about rhaenyra and Daemon
because they are uncle and niece getting
married people are angry like Targaryen
incest is is fine as far as the
targaryens are concerned the problem
with Daemon and Rainier's marriage is
that they didn't get permission from the
King to do it and they married
immediately after the deaths of their
respective spouses Lenor and Lena and so
that's just seen as an insult and it's
just out of everyone's control and no
permission and that's why that is an
issue thanks for the Super Chat from
Robbie who says they're gonna ruin larus
like they did with Baelish by making him
overtly Sinister slash creepy yeah I
think that's a fair point because
Littlefinger in the TV show like he
started out being kind of subtle like
you know what is this guy's deal like we
don't know exactly what what
Littlefinger wants and what he's up to
but but then very quickly Littlefinger
devolved into like a mustache twirling
evil dude Evil Genius who who spoke in a
voice like this and he was like Sansa I
want to have the throne and he was
obviously a bad guy in the later Seasons
um and they are doing something similar
with Laris because Laris in the books is
very ambiguous I mean everyone's kind of
ambiguous in the books because there's
so little detail in Fire and Blood
um but I agree they're making larys very
obviously a bad guy and that might sort
of undermine the ambiguity that makes
him interesting
um we've got a little bit of
um technical uh complications from Adobe
here thanks Adobe your annual
subscription is really paying off uh
thanks for the Super Chat from Olivia
who says that scene of aemond hanging on
to Vega's Reigns made my stomach flip
yeah I I thought it was fun and I
thought it was visceral when amond was
being flung about on Vega's back
um we a bit of technical difficulties
but uh yeah that was that was a cool
scene oh my [ __ ] god uh
okay adobe's unhappy
um
please bear with me
uh God [ __ ] damn it
uh thanks for the Super Chat
from
merciful who says watching the kids try
to explain what happened to the adults
talking over one another it was so
realistic I know a kid lost an eye but
they were beat up and that's how kids
actually argue yeah
yeah there's a line in the books about
um the the cruelty of children is well
known
um and so yeah these children I think
are almost as bad at conflict resolution
as their parents are
sorry for the technical difficulties
blame the Adobe Corporation
[ __ ] hell
uh technical difficulties
sorry about this
uh give me a second
oh my God
I hope we will be back shortly
okay
hopefully we're back
thanks for the Super Chat from Harrison
who says could daemon's Hood be like a
reverse Fight Club it's like things the
rumors said which he did which were
completely uninvolved
um
you're saying that like a reverse Fight
Club you're saying that Daemon like
didn't really kill Reya
I'm not sure what you mean Harrison
thanks for Super Chat from KO who says
boy go skizzid to the face thank you KO
thank you Cairo thank you herder who
says how much should Jace and Luke fear
Daemon
why should Jace and Luke via Daemon yeah
okay all right I see what you I see what
you're saying
um because now the Daemon has married
rain era they might produce children
because that's what uh marriages do in
this world and in our world
um and thing is uh Daemon is now a
stepfather to Jace and Luke and Joffrey
and step parents don't always get along
with their step children
it agrees me to say
um so it might be that Daemon being a
sort of a murderous ambitious guy maybe
Daemon wants Jace and Luke and Joff dead
so that his own children with Rainier
Oak can inherit Rainier's Throne
um that would not be unprecedented so
yeah that's an interesting idea maybe
Jason Luke should be afraid of their new
stepdad Daemon
um
uh you know and Damon also has Baylor
and Rayna to think about so yeah I think
that's an interesting point heard uh
thanks for the Super Chat from cital Ali
who says why would the King's Guard not
try to break up the Alison Rainier fight
yeah I mean I think they just wanted a
dramatic moment but yeah I mean if I was
some of these kingsguard I think it
would be a good idea to not let the
queen kill the princess uh they just
sort of like formed a circle and
everyone's just like ah let's see how
this plays out
they just enjoyed watching it go down
when yeah I think they should have
intervened thanks with super chat from
Alvarado who says do you think that
Rainier planned the Lenor Escape yeah I
mean I think Daemon was in on it
um and I guess Serena was as well
because yeah there was some dialogue I
didn't see it at first but there was
some dialogue where they said Grant him
this kindness set him free
um so was Daemon saying that to Carl or
was Damon saying that to Rainier I'll
have to re-watch but uh I guess rhaenyra
was in on it yeah letting them go
especially after the conversation that
Rainier I had with Lena
thanks for the Super Chat from Mitch we
already talked about dayron Targaryen
there is another son who I think will
appear later in the show because there
are four blood streams coming from Alice
and in the opening sequence thanks for
the Super Chat from Christian yeah yeah
it's almost like Laris is sort of like
gaslighting Allison into thinking that
Larissa's ideas are what Alison wants
you know like I think lariss is sort of
playing mind games with Alison
manipulating her
um I wonder if he's gonna try and
control her and I wonder if Alison is
going to allow that thanks for the Super
Chat from Jack who says why not use both
men Lenor is a warrior Dragon Rider and
political Ally Rainier could have kids
with Daemon who look like Lenor oh and
the rumors give all the boys legitimacy
that that's an interesting idea I think
you're right that like if Rainier had
some bastard kids with Daemon if Rainier
didn't marry Daemon and instead stayed
married to Lenor and had kids with
Daemon anyway they would look Valyrian
and they would stop the rumors about
bastardy hopefully
um and dear Leno is a very valuable Ally
because he's a dragon rider so yeah
maybe the smart thing to do would have
been to stay married to Leno and have
kids with have kids with Daemon anyway
I I don't think it's meant to be like
the most rational political decision for
rhaenyra and Daemon to marry each other
like clearly this is partly about sexual
desire with them and you know both of
them are these rebellious people I think
I think this is an act of defiance
against their family and Defiance
against the system they're trying to
express their true Desires in defiance
of everybody else so yeah it might not
be the most politically smart idea to
get rid of Lenor a valuable Ally and to
you know piss people off you know like
especially you know the alliance with
the valerians is so important so uh
getting rid of Leno is probably not a
good idea in that respect either
um we're not going to talk about future
characters just yet thanks for the Super
Chat from Sherry who says did you like
Westworld season four I haven't seen it
yet but I look forward to seeing it uh
thank you Nikolai who says I like how
this show actually shows difficult
conversations being had unlike the
cutaways every time a tough conversation
comes up in Game of Thrones season eight
yeah I agree with that there were a lot
of moments in Game of Thrones season 8
where it's like oh I wonder how Sansa
and Arya will react to finding out that
Jon is actually the son of rhaegar
Targaryen but instead of showing us the
conversation it just cuts away here in
episode four
um
there were multiple moments like that I
I like like the like a large chunk of
the final episode of Game of Thrones
season eight the final episode of the
series had no dialogue in it and that
can be a legitimate artistic Choice like
you can let the visuals speak for
themselves and their actors faces speak
but uh I think that in that case it just
showed that they couldn't think of
anything good for the characters to say
I think in that case it was a failure of
writing that there was so little
dialogue in the final episode
so yeah I think hot day is better in
that respect thanks so who says Jess and
Luke have a dad who's as fun as an uncle
yeah so jacaris and luceris now have
Daemon as a stepdad and maybe that will
be fun uh farico
speculates that uh Rayna Targaryen might
claim sea smoke maybe Raina didn't get
to claim her mother Lena's Dragon Vega
maybe she will get to cut to claim her
uncle's Dragon sea smoke sure thanks for
the Super Chat from Ash who says that
Allison's thinly veiled
self-righteousness is insufferable all I
see is subconscious resentment of
rhaenyra and the kingdom will suffer for
it yeah I mean Alison says as much
doesn't she like Alison says
um you've flaunt what exactly is a word
what exactly does Alison say to Rainier
like like she is angry at you know
Rainier's Behavior
forever upholding the kingdom the family
the law Allison feels like she's been
doing it but rhaenyra has been flaunting
it all to do as she pleases so it's all
the same stuff we talked about last week
Alison feeling resentful that Rainier
Breaks the Rules while Alison has to
follow the rules
thanks Mike who says they could have had
a lot of eggs during the pre-conquest
and Conquest times but not enough kids
to bond with Slash hatch them yeah I
mean maybe dragon eggs you can sort of
leave dragon eggs in storage for a while
and the eggs will only hatch when they
are when they are close to a Targaryen
who could bond with them yeah like like
they only brought five dragons from
valyria to Dragonstone but maybe they
brought a whole bunch of eggs and maybe
the eggs only hatch when there is a
Targaryen to ride them like maybe like
that there isn't a lot of clarity about
how that works in the books so yeah I
think that's that's worthy speculation
uh ranak says was that Leno at the end
yeah Leno and Carl rode into the sunset
like Gendry Gunner says amond is ice
cold insulting his auntie and stealing
her Dragon what was the Valyrian phrase
he commanded to Vega yeah aemon said
some word uh
he's likiri
I uh my my valyrian's a little bit Rusty
I haven't learned it on Duolingo yet I
don't know what likiri means he did also
I mean to hire us we know means like
serve like obey
um but amond also said solves
which I guess means fly I'm assuming
from context
thanks for the Super Chat from Dish who
says did you notice that aegon says
brother when Otto kicks him from his
drunken stupor did amond regularly fight
back when amond was drunk yeah there was
that interesting moment
where Auto Hightower like found aegon
drunk in a stairwell at the funeral
um and I I like that because it sort of
suggested that like Otto is the one guy
who can actually sort of carouse
everyone and bring a bit of order you
know like everyone at this funeral is
just sort of wandering around getting
drunk having sex with their Uncle like
Rainier is with Daemon But Otto is the
guy who's like okay let's let's behave
ourselves let's be proper here like Otto
is going to try and kick some order into
this situation because viserys is
increasingly letting go of the Reigns as
his you know his body falls apart
literally and his mind is falling apart
thinking that Alison is Emma so I think
that Otto is going to attempt to assert
some order to this court and I think
that he is going to certainly favor
Allison over anyone else but um I mean
yeah with aegon and amond like we've
seen aegon bully amond and yeah it's
weird that aegon initially thought that
Otto was aemond I wonder why okay like
why did aegon assume that Otto was the
one kicking him maybe kicking people is
something that aemond does maybe aegon
was just thinking about aemond I don't
know thanks for the Super Chat from
Master Cheese who says what would Otto
say to Alison if he found out that she
had rejected Rainier's proposal to marry
josaris to Helena yeah maybe Otto would
have been Machiavellian and smart enough
to seriously consider marrying Allison's
kid to Rainier as kid
um like Otto did say that like oh
conflict is inevitable but I think that
Otto may have seen that as an
opportunity for peace because like Otto
Aldo doesn't sound like he wants War as
such he just believes that war is
inevitable
um and unlike Alison Otto doesn't have
as much like skin in the game like Otto
doesn't have like a deep emotional
grudge against rhaenyra like Alison does
so Otto might not be as against the idea
of marrying them together but you know
maybe it's also possible that Otto would
have said no like don't marry your
daughter to a bastard that only
compromises us so yeah yeah that's an
interesting idea maybe Otto would have
been cool with that
thanks for the Super Chat from beep boop
who says I have a theory that since Vega
hatched closer to the time of valyria
she's more obedient and obeys any blood
of the Dragon who isn't a dragon rider
uh I don't see evidence for that I mean
maybe I mean I think Vegas should be
like different to other dragons like
because vegar is older and sort of from
a different generation she isn't like
these young whipper snapper dragons
around these days who don't listen to
their parents but um
yeah she could be a bit different and
they had that line in the dragon pit
last episode about like once you bond
with the Dragon no one else like the
dragon won't obey anyone else which
which again emphasize is how significant
it is that aemond is the one person in
the world who controls the biggest
dragon in the world
uh duff duff says that Lenor promised to
do what rhaenyra wants
Yeah well yeah yeah that yeah so
duffduff is saying that maybe lane or
didn't like want to run away as much as
Lena just obeyed Rainier like Rainier
ordered lane or to run away I mean we
saw in the previous episode that
rhaenyra ordered Lane order to stand by
her
um so maybe once again Rainier ordered
lane or she countermanded that and said
no I actually want you to leave like
nymeria and Arya in Game of Thrones
season one thanks for Rico thanks Kick W
who says why did Daemon kill Leno's
lover to kill Lenor he actually paid him
to fake Lane or's death and leave but in
the books it seems as though Damon may
actually have ordered Carl to kill Lenor
um but they did it so that Daemon and
Rainier could marry
Tanya says the scene gave me flashbacks
of Bobby B coming back from the north
and having to kill lady yeah there
absolutely is a parallel between that
situation after the fight with Arya and
Joffrey and this fight uh thanks left of
today who says I want Alison to have a
bastard child to spite of viserys since
he doesn't seem to care I mean hey like
do we even have proof that aegon and
Helena and uh amond are all viserys's
children do we have proof maybe Alison
hooked up with some some uh Valerian
person and had those kids with someone
else it would be the ultimate hypocrisy
if Alison had a bastard and it would be
hilarious uh there is a line in one of
the books that says that uh Alison was
deflowered by Daemon so maybe aegon
Targaryen is actually secretly the
bastard of Alison and Daemon I don't
think that that's true but we could
speculate thanks Tanya and thanks ranak
who says that Alison was horrified when
laras had Harwin burned but rhaenyra
seems to barely give a second thought
when Daemon talks of removing Lenor yeah
but I think she then agreed to actually
let Lenor live but um yeah look Rainier
is a Targaryen there's violence and fire
in her and I think that uh no one's
hands are going to be clean at the end
of this series uh Braden says that Lenor
is quaith the masked woman in Game of
Thrones season two thanks dark Aura
thanks Haley who says I think the only
way a Jon Snow spin-off show works is if
bran becomes the main villain maybe bran
is an evil tree King yeah I mean if you
consider the book law it makes perfect
sense that King brand the broken uh is
evil
uh I think that if you consider the book
law it makes a lot of sense that the
person who we think of as bran is
actually now just an agent of bloodraven
the three-eyed Crow
um because I mean they say in the show
that like bran says I am not bran
anymore I am the three-eyed Raven now
um he loses his personality and I think
he becomes a vessel for the old gods
maybe not bloodraven specifically more
just the old gods in general
um George Martin has a history of
writing about uh scary evil Hive Minds
controlling everything so I think that
uh it'll be really interesting to see
how this series ends in the books
because the books are very different to
the TV show The Original Series
um and if and when George ever finishes
those books I think that bran being King
might be a very dark and spooky thing as
opposed to a bland wet fart as it was in
the Game of Thrones show
tamash says I wish I knew daemon's
motives he seemed to want the throne but
with Lena he was uninspired maybe
marrying rhaenyra will restore his
passion I agree tamash I think that
Daemon marrying rhaenyra is him going
okay fine I tried running away in pentos
I tried denying my ambition I tried
letting go I tried being content but
[ __ ] it I'm a Targaryen I want power I
want my niece I want to just burn things
and make Fire and Blood and I'm just
here to cause some Havoc let's do it
like yeah I think Daemon is getting back
to old classic original Daemon like he
tried to be new Coke Daemon now he's the
original recipe baby and I think he's
gonna make some fire thanks for the
Super Chat from DD how did Rainier and
Daemon convince lane or off-screen to
Stage his own death to run away right
after he promised to be better yeah well
said
I think that we sort of have to
speculate in our own minds how exactly
that worked because yeah lane or kind of
did spin on a dime there to abandon his
entire life but you know I think that
you know he loves Carl and he doesn't
love politics so he's willing to give up
his political life to embrace his Karl
life
Saint Darwin says this saint Darwin uh
Saint Darwin says it's midnight [ __ ]
Mondays enjoyed the podcast gotta go to
bed good night Emma uh Survivor
challenges says do you think Helena will
be one of the more sympathetic
characters yeah so like Helena in the
books does not have much personality
there is very little description of like
what kind of person Helena Targaryen is
let's get a picture of Helena bloody
Targaryen like I think the books
describe Helena as being like uh plump
and happy and that's like as much
description as we get uh so I think that
Elena's depiction in House of the Dragon
is infinitely more interesting
um and I think that making her a dreamer
is a really good choice because like as
a dreamer she doesn't have to like do
things that she didn't do in the books
like they don't have to make any massive
deviations that contradict the books but
as a dreamer she can say things that
give us insights and give us
foreshadowing and raise her questions
maybe it'll connect to the prophecy and
there are later things that happen that
might make Helena's prophecies personal
to her there's a lot of cool things that
they could do there so yeah I think that
I'm glad that they've done what they did
with Helena and yeah like a sympathetic
character is is something they could do
with her because
um I think Alison and uh potentially
rhaenyra are not great as far as people
go so maybe Helena can be one of those
more sort of relatable people who is
like you know reacting as we would react
to the atrocities happening around her
Beggars says it's odd that viewers
assume assume Daenerys and Rainier would
kill Alison's kids in power especially
after viserys was chosen with several
other claimants without incident yeah I
mean that's that's a thing isn't it like
like this show started with the council
at Harren Hall which showed a disputed
succession being resolved and then no
one died so you can sort of interpret
that as like well maybe they should just
do that again like maybe they should
host a another great Council and instead
of stabbing each other they should just
sit down and hold a vote with the Lords
as they did at Harren hall and then they
can decide
um but another way of interpreting it is
that that that council at harrenhal and
like skipping over rhaenys and choosing
viserys instead you can also say that
well that never was a real solution no
one was well I mean some people were but
a lot of people were unhappy with that
like call us
um and that that solution was never
really going to work like they were
building on an unstable Foundation
from the beginning so like it was always
rotten it was always going to fall this
has been a Jenga Tower with fewer and
fewer blocks getting more and more
rickety year by year Generation by
generation and this collapses the
natural consequence of that you know so
there's a few different ways you can
look at it thanks to thanks Justin who
says I love you Brianna good night alt
shift X I haven't watched yet Levi says
don't know if it was mentioned but it
was interesting that Kristen didn't obey
Alison yeah I think Kristen is less of a
loose cannon now than he was before the
10-year Gap and I think Kristen decided
that cutting out the third in line to
the throne luceros valerion in front of
everybody was probably a bad idea uh
thanks Liz balito who says maybe the
rings of power writers will learn how to
adapt a story Brandon says do you think
rhaenyra will tell rhaenys about Lenor
oh that's a cool idea Brandon because
yeah like Rainier made Lane no disappear
and rhaenys was very upset about the
apparent death of her only son maybe
Rainier could say hey
um Auntie rhaenys uh don't worry he's
actually fine sorry for putting a corpse
in your fireplace
I hope the smell I hope you can remove
the smell from the drapes uh thanks Matt
who says that Lionel seems like one of
the few selfless advisers yeah that's
what viseris said of his hand of the
king Lionel strong but apparently the
one unbiased guy who just wanted his
family to survive got barbecued by his
own son Laris so alas there is uh there
are very few unbiased peaceful men left
in this story
Harrison says I thought Daemon and
Rainier applauded the fake murder
together uh yep and yeah cultivating a
Machiavellian fear in the in the public
yeah that that is part of it like
rhaenyra is saying Rainier and daemon's
are saying like let's fake Leno's death
but make it look like we did it right
Nira and Daemon are deliberately uh
trying to make people afraid of them by
pretending to have murdered her husband
so so like that that is the beginning of
the marriage their marriage started with
a deliberately fake murder to make
people afraid of them like my God what
what a honeymoon you know like uh so
that really sets things off on a
smart dangerous scary foot doesn't it
much like larous's smart scary dangerous
foot abadi says I kept convincing myself
that Joffrey was talking about another
time period
uh okay thanks for the Super Chat from
Andrew who says I absolutely love Larry
strong African sci-fi scholar says I'm
sure the dragon pit mechanics will not
be happy about seeing Veigar again not
that old school bus yeah I mean if you
have to change the oil and repair the
gaskets I think Vega would be a
dilapidated old dragon with a lot of
aches and pains in her old grandma body
um I'm not sure Veigar would even fit in
the dragon pit didn't Lane didn't Lana
valerion say that previously she said
that Vega is too big for the dragon pit
so maybe they won't be the dragon
Keeper's problem
Mega says do dragons have their own
opinions of each other would it be based
on the Dragon Riders relationships or
would they have their own rivalries I
think that's a good question I mean we
saw in the previous episode that vegar
was reluctant to kill Lena which
suggests that dragons like do
have their own thoughts and feelings and
Vega then agreed to kill Lana which
might suggest that Vega perhaps
psychically felt Lena's pain or just
practiced some compassion but like you
know since the Starks can control
animals through skin changing a lot of
people speculate that the targaryens
control dragons through a similar form
of skin changing like on some psychic
unconscious level because really like
obviously like you know there's no way
the dragons can hear the targaryens on
their backs shouting drukaros through
all of the wind and stuff and like how
would the dragons know who the rider
wants them to dracarus like dragons
always seem to somehow know which Target
they are meant to burn like the dragons
know who is on their Rider's side and
who isn't so I think it would make a lot
of sense if there is a psychic
connection there
Sasha says that Alison is acting like
the righteous one but she's trying to
steal Rainier's Birthright and Advance
her own interests like yeah but like
also Allison is right the rhaenyra's
kids are bastards and therefore legally
shouldn't inherit the throne depending
on who you ask so you know they
definitely are playing both sides with
Alison there like she partly it's
personal partly it's political
um the 13 rulers of calf have the same
cicada symbol as the one Laris strong
uses says Leaf is that true
uh
uh I see a bunch of different symbols on
the 13 in Game of Thrones season 2
episode 4. uh I'm seeing a lot of
different necklaces
I'm not seeing a firefly badge do you oh
do you mean these you mean these things
so we're talking about Firefly of Laris
looks like this
so are you saying that that is the same
as that
I don't know what do you think Chad are
the 13 rulers of carth secretly working
for Lara strong all along
yeah look I uh I'm doubtful but I I like
your Keen eyes yeah that yeah well they
do all seem to have those little golden
Clips don't they
yeah look maybe Larry maybe maybe that
is hilarious maybe the clubfoot lives
anyway uh thanks for the Super Chat from
hildre
who says right near a set lane or free
yeah I I think that
I I think that that was the plan uh
thanks Robin who says is Alison pregnant
uh
uh I don't think she would hide being
pregnant I don't think she is pregnant
but uh we'll we'll find out uh William
says that
uh something about a spoiler Daemon
accepts Rainier's power and agency we've
been talking for a long time so we've
got to end this I'm gonna quickly answer
as many super chats as I can uh Robert
says rhaenyra is becoming my least
favorite character total narcissist who
pays no mind to the consequences of her
actions
yeah Rainier uh I mean she was trying to
be restrained in the confrontation with
Alison
um but marrying Daemon like this is
certainly going to have consequences
thanks Curtis William Catlin and Sunkist
says that they know abandoned sea smoke
yeah it's sad well I bet you know maybe
sea smoke will follow maybe Lena said yo
is he smoke we're going over here maybe
maybe see smoke will follow like a dog
that that finds its owner
um thanks for the Super Chat from
Christian who says likiri is similar to
umbas in High Valyrian meaning calm I
can see someone's been on Duolingo uh a
Taha we already talked about Deron
Targaryen I think he might turn up later
bill says if Daemon and rhaenyra die in
a dragon accident will Laris adopt his
nephews
laris's nephews you mean oh right yeah
well Jace Luke and Joff are Harwin
Strong's children so yeah if Daemon and
rhaenyra died maybe uh Laris could say
hey those are my brother harwin's
bastards so I will adopt them and they
can live in harrenhal as strongs I mean
Laris needs some heirs right so unless
Laris uh is gonna marry and have kids
maybe Jace Luke and Joff are his uh
heirs yeah that's that's an interesting
idea for sure
um Nelly says Lionel shaved his head
like egg but in the history books he's
murdered in spicetown on driftmark so
are the history books wrong
uh I mean yeah the books certainly
explore the idea of the history books
being wrong and the books say that it's
a mystery like why Carl killed Lenor I
think it is plausible that you know for
the purposes of the show they actually
faked Leno's death
um and yeah they changed where it
happened like it happens in high tide
instead of in spicetown which is a town
on driftmark so yeah look they are
changing the lore of the books a little
bit but I think it's a cool and mostly
consistent idea that you know it was a
faked death you know like this is what
they sort of got to do like that they
have to add mystery and subtlety to the
very brief description in the book
uh Tammy Lee says that Laris probably
doesn't care that he's the uncle to Luke
and and Jace yeah I I don't think larris
strikes me as someone who wants a couple
of nephews or a few nephews Kamal asks
about dayron I think we may see him
later uh Sasha says why didn't yasaris
say amond was about to smash Luke's head
in with a rock I think he did I I think
I think Jace did say he was trying to
kill Luke or something like well one of
the boys said he was trying to kill them
so I think they tried to say that but
yeah the children did not communicate
very well but also like who cares like
they all were in on the brawl you know I
don't know if it would really benefit
anyone for them to try and litigate who
did what exactly I think I mean I mean
amond was a giant [ __ ] but like the
other kids also were involved I don't
know it's not going to make anyone happy
like Amon lost an eye like what do you
want Bubba Says do you think we will see
any stories that will allow us to see
live action version versions of the Far
East or South there are a lot of
different spin-offs happening I mean the
nymerias 10 000 ships spin-off show that
they have started developing
um that would visit sothorios so that
would be cool and they're also talking
about a nine voyages show about callus
and that would go to Yeti and ashai and
lots of places so theoretically yeah we
could see some of those exotic locales
in live action Casey says why did amond
blame
aegon instead of Alison not sure what
you mean Curtis says not killing lane or
felt like a cop-out I I think that like
part of why I like sparing Lena is that
we don't want too much repetition like I
think that the reason why uh Elena
valarion died by Dragon last episode
instead of just dying in childbirth as
um she did in the books is that Emma
Aaron just died in childbirth in episode
one and they don't want two characters
dying exactly the same way it's kind of
boring and repetitive and pointless
um Lenor is one of many characters who
is allegedly murdered in the books
uh there's going to be lots of murders
in this series so far and in future and
I think that by adding some interesting
deviations and subtleties like hey Lane
was actually alive like that that
creates a bit of that's that's more
interesting than if everyone's just well
he got murdered then he got murdered
then she got murdered you know I like
the variety
Manny says rhaenyra and Lena were made
to look more good in this episode
yeah and yeah and I agree with you that
it's good that they said multiple times
that Lena and Rainier did try to
conceive a child together because that
is one of you know it would have been a
lot better for everyone if Leno and
Rainier had a true born child who looked
Valerian because then this whole issue
of bastardy and questioned inheritance
would not be as much of an issue um so
yeah it does make them look more good
that they're like yeah like we did try
to make a child but we couldn't and I
wonder if that's like I don't know
without getting too graphic
um I wonder why that didn't work because
like I mean you know obviously Lena was
gay but you know in Game of Thrones
Marjorie was saying that like hey like
Loris I mean Renly why don't you just
like get warmed up with Loris and then
you can impregnate me
um maybe Leno and Rainier could have
tried something like that or maybe Lenor
is infertile and maybe that's why he
couldn't produce children
um who knows
hildra says that Daemon was pretty calm
this episode yeah Daemon I think was um
still any sort of relaxed mode after his
marriage with Lena but I think that
re-embracing Rainier really puts him
back on a path of Fire and Blood
Juan says do you think that Laris knows
that Lena is alive that's a good
question
because Laris does know things that he
has no right knowing like how did Laris
know that Milos gave rhaenyra T
previously so you know if laryus has a
network of spies or if he has skin
changing Powers however he knows what he
knows maybe he's also aware about Lane
law and maybe lane or is in danger
rhaenyra said multiple times she tried
to have kids with Lenor yep we did talk
about that as well it does make Rainier
seem more heroic and Alice and more
villainous this episode I think Nimbus
says is Melisandre alive during this
time we don't know exactly how old
Melisandre is uh Karis the actor in the
show said that she's hundreds of years
old in the books it's like implied that
she might be very old but it's not clear
so it is possible yeah that Melisandre
is alive she might look different she
could be played by a different actor
because I think that melisandre's
appearance is a glamor it's a magical
illusion and are there other red
priestesses yeah I mean the religion of
relore has been around for a long time
so there are lots of red priests
especially in places like volantis but
there's not a lot of red priests and
priestesses in Westeros Christian says
in the books lane or was killed by Carl
but the show probably made it so that
the maesters believed it yeah the
maesters are often wrong about their
interpretations of History
Tommy says Daemon and rhaenyra are
really the main characters yeah I think
that rhaenyra is probably meant to be or
sort of I think is the most sympathetic
main Central character but she has done
a lot wrong as well like you know from
the varsity and the lies and from then
on so uh I mean Daemon is also a very
Central character but he is a murderer
like he's murdered quite a lot of people
he's a chaotic [ __ ] so you know he's
he might not be as sympathetic as the
others
um Casey says why did aemon say he heard
the bastard thing from his brother I
don't know he was being honest like he's
a child the the king is confronting him
um and I think that he probably did hear
it from his brother aegon is exactly the
sort of person who would say that uh the
strongs are bastards uh and Allison
might not ever have said to amond that
the Strong's a bastards so I think
aemond was probably telling the truth uh
Sasha says that Alison doesn't like that
the second in line is a bastard but
rhaenyra is the heir in theory she could
still have legitimate Sons once Queen
yeah well if Rainier marries Daemon
um if Rainier has children with Daemon
they would be true Bond children
and according to the laws those trueborn
children would inherit the throne ahead
of irania's bastard children so in
theory uh rhaenyra and Daemon having
kids solves everything
but of course in practice it will not
solve everything because people have
feelings uh and grudges and Ambitions
and uh axes to grind so uh I I suspect
that it might just make things more
complicated but I mean you know it is an
interesting question like if Daemon and
Rainier have kids
will Daemon want those kids to inherit
the throne ahead of Jace Luke and
Joffrey so maybe Daemon wants people to
see Jace Luke and Joffrey as bastards
that we'll see how that plays out
vasoon says the greens need a bit more
sympathy or support yeah I think that uh
Alison and her side seem more villainous
and I mean that is something that people
say about the book is that sometimes the
greens seem more like the villainous
side so we'll see if the show changes
that or or what Gabriel says did Daemon
actually want lane or dead I think that
the plan was to let Leno and Carl Go
free VA says that viserys if viserys
discovered how Otto was placing Alison
in front of him wouldn't that somewhat
delegitimate her kids I mean in like an
emotional sense like yeah viserys knows
that Otto put Alison in front of him so
it's like
he might not like that whole Union and
those children as much like he might not
want aegon to be Heir given that aegon
is the product of Otto's manipulations
in a sense like I see what you're saying
but uh he made the kids the kids exist
and uh you know he does love Allison
still you know I mean what's interesting
is that viserys made
Otto hand of the King again even though
he already realized that Otto was
manipulative so he's just gotten over
that has he like I wonder if Otto just
sort of muscled his way in and viseryos
is like fine okay whatever take it you
can be handed the king and viserys you
know he's mistaking Allison for Emma
like he's got a bit of dementia like
maybe he just wasn't maybe his mind was
not together enough to realize that he
shouldn't make Otto hand of the king
lots of speculation there uh user says
can someone claim C smoke if Lena isn't
dead I think that that's an open
question because there's never been a
dragon that's been claimed by a new
Rider while the old rider is still alive
so um it's a mystery okay we're gonna
end it here
um
tambilee says Lane Oil was killed by
Carl
so they assumed that's how when it went
down yeah they they covered up the The
Escape of Lanos or the maesters wouldn't
know that Leonor is still alive okay
thank you so much for participating
everybody
um thank you for the super chats let's
have a quick look at the on the next
episode preview and then we're going to
end the Stream
uh so if you do not want to see the on
the next episode trailer preview thing
then you might like Look Away now we're
just gonna have a quick glance and then
we're going to end the stream please
press like And subscribe
um and whatever you do don't check out
the alt drift X YouTube channel
um
and uh by the way if you're looking for
other cool analysis of this show you
might like to check out uh history of
Westeros and the ringer podcast that we
mentioned in this stream uh if you're
looking for more good hot tea analysis
okay let's look at the preview so
there is a ship I like them it's got a
little a little dome in it that looks
great
Otto appears to be asserting his
authority as the hand of the king uh the
hand of the king sometimes sits on the
Iron Throne to represent the king and
the King's power when the king is unwell
and I think that viserys may
increasingly be unwell in the near
future so Otto might be making moves to
support his daughter and undermine
Rainier which will be interesting to see
Rainier is still here there's been a
time Skip by the way we've jumped ahead
several years uh so that's uh Jace or
Luke and that's Baylor or Rayna they're
played by new actors I know that some
people have been annoyed by the time
skips because they're a bit disorienting
with the new actors and everything
changing but I think that this is the
last big time skip I think this is the
last time skip that will recast actors I
think these actors are the ones that we
can actually finally get attached to
because they going to stick around as
long as anyone will stick around in this
show the hightowers land their first
blow ooh what blow were they Landing oh
look at the grown-up kids so there's
grown-up uh amond Targaryen he lost his
eye in this episode now in the next
episode he's got a fetching eye patch
like you're on Greyjoy uh we've got
aegon here and we've got Helena side
Hightower all grown up and look at the
faith of the seven necklace that Alison
has there that's great so the faith of
the seven is is the religion that Alison
follows and I think that you know
embracing the symbolism of the faith is
a smart political move for Alison
because she's saying that I'm the
religious one I'm the one who follows
the rules I'm the one that's not sinful
unlike that sinful rule-breaking bastard
bastard having Rainier a Targaryen and
you know the faith is associated with
old town and and the high Towers so it
makes sense for her to do that as like a
bit of political symbolism uh aegon
there yeah more faith of the seven stuff
maybe this is about the marriage of
aegon and Helena maybe that's what this
is
I wasn't looking quite powerful and
political with her outfit here and
looking very green which indicates you
know they're against the blacks
Ryanair is talking about Otto and the
high Towers you know basically running
running the show politically uh in
viserys's name I wonder if viserys has
lost any more body parts I hope viserys
is doing well uh Daemon says to King's
Landing so are they on Dragonstone at
the moment maybe they hang on maybe they
hang out on Dragonstone for a while but
in the meantime
Otto shows up Hightower power on King's
Landing is that viserys in childbed what
is with the desaturated gray look is
that like a dream or something there's
like fog everywhere that's mysterious
and cool the sea smoke has taken a grave
wound in the books he just like gets
sick because he's very old the seasoning
is very old at this point like I think
he's like 70 or 80 around this era
um he's an old man in the books I hope
that they make him look old because he
should be old
uh he's taken a wound and that raises
the question of who gets to inherit his
castle high tide and driftmark who gets
to be the next lord of the valerions and
I think vemond is setting himself up as
a claimant to driftmark but you know we
know that rhaenys wants Baylor uh to
wants wants her granddaughter Baylor to
inherit riftmark so
there may be some conflict there who
will take the Driftwood Throne the
Throne of house valerion uh viserys says
the house of the Dragon can't be United
it can't be uh conflicted but it is
divided uh Jace and Luke's new actors
here
they're going to be significant all
grown up what is that blurry thing
Daemon is taking a dragon egg I wonder
who Daemon is getting a dragon egg for
what is Daemon going to do with that
dragon egg
um maybe he's getting it for Raina maybe
his daughter Raina is gonna get that
dragon egg so that you can finally get a
dragon oh mazaria Missouri is back
mazaria the white worm and some hooded
figure is that Daemon in that hood or is
that one of Missouri's spies one of her
informants will mazaria still be working
with Otto Hightower
what is the deal uh amond is looking
deranged in this scene which I
absolutely love he's looking quite
freaky and scary and he says nephews so
I guess he's referring to Jace and Luke
the people who cut out his eye so aemond
is probably not very friendly with those
people uh and it looks like there's a
fight between Jason Luke and amond and
aegon so uh yeah the house of the Dragon
is sure looking divided viserys the
threat of War looms were starting to get
real vemond is asserting his power I
reckon he wants drift Mark and that is
what we will see on the next episode
okay we're gonna end the live stream
here thank you so much for participating
like And subscribe and we'll see you
next time
thanks Christian thanks Tanya thanks
everyone and I apologize uh for any
super chats that I missed and have a
good one till next time see you cheers